what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
[Applause]
after I start do not forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos as you
guys already know if you have watched
two or more of my lives and you do not
subscribe we have beef okay beef people
um make sure you like the video on your
way in and a couple announcements before
we start the show the first is that we
have two clips channels the first is
just Pearl Eclipse I believe we just hit
200k on that and the second is Pearl
daily which is at around 30 30k um we
have two different editors on the
eclipse channel so you get two different
types of content if you subscribe to
both
um so make sure you go subscribe the
second thing is that we have four
membership tiers the first tier is going
to allow you to be a part of the live
chat tonight the second tier is going to
allow you to be a part of our Discord
and our behind the scenes blogs the
third tier you are going to get to
connect with me on social media and the
fourth dear you get a one-on-one call
with me once a month I recommend using
this to grow on YouTube if you want to
know the ins and outs of running a live
show I would recommend that tier it's
definitely worth the money I have a lot
of insights that and a lot of tips that
will help you avoid a lot of the
problems that I had early on okay second
y'all they took away my Instagram I know
I know um I know
um so go follow my new Instagram just
pearly things one I'm already at 7K
followers so um try to get to ten we're
hoping to get 10 by the end of the week
um also go follow my Tick Tock I'm on my
final morning on just pearlythings.5 so
go follow that one and if that gets
banned I have just pearly things six so
go follow that too
yeah it don't matter though because it's
funny no matter how many accounts they
take they can't get rid of me off of
either app I'm all over the blog Pages
nah you can't get rid of me
um also make sure you guys go subscribe
to wife school if you are at 304 are you
at 304 and you want to be a wife we have
the place for you we call it wife school
um so go subscribe to the channel we
have episode one of wife school um
dropping probably this week
and all super chats are going towards
blessings monopod of so if you want to
up the quality of our street interviews
make sure you donate um and all
donations will be read today over what
should we do blessing over ten dollars
five dollars
over 50. that's it really good all right
you know what blessings has over fifty
dollars
um so all super chat's over 50. I might
allow 20. um okay um so today we have a
lovely panel um so why don't we go
around everyone say your name your age
your relationship status and a a fun
interesting fact about yourself um could
just be a fun fact you know or it could
be you know something that you like to
do whatever so let's go first row um and
then second row so you can start and
then go around ooh okay uh so my name is
Kyla I like to show people it's like you
have a key and then your eye and then la
like you're saying so uh yeah so key
Isla
um I'm from New York uh my relationship
is single but I'm always mingling so you
know it's
it's iffy um so you're open yeah so okay
okay
um and what were the other questions a
fun fact about myself yeah fun fact
um
I learned how to sing my ABCs backwards
when I was three so oh okay yeah show me
a little bit
um z y x w v t s r q p o n m l k j i h e
f e b c e d c b a that's the bus
[Applause]
all right go ahead go ahead I did not
know you could do that she's a woman of
many talents clearly oh that is so cool
um hey you guys I'm Aurora I'm 26. this
is my cousin
um I'm also American I'm from Virginia
and
um what is it relationship name age
relationship status yeah so Roar 26 I'm
single and fun fact I'm an American who
recently moved to London so
that is my fun fact
hi I'm Shanique I'm 19. my relationship
state is I'm currently single
fun fact I'll just say I'll study acting
and performance at the moment so that's
just probably what I'm gonna say for
that
so yeah
hey my name is Cairo I'm 20 and
um your name is relationships
and I'm also studying acting and
performance with shilique as well yeah
uh my name is Stephen I am 35 I am
seeing somebody currently and a fun fact
I create a mobile app that will allow
people to find out if the person they're
seeing ding or speaking to is seeing
dating or speaking to anybody else at
the same time oh wow
we use a unique identifier to uh pair
people for relatable chats up I'd have
to explain to you properly it's a
the best way to put it is it like facial
recognition like type stuff no simpler
than that it's a lot simpler
um we pretty much use a unique
identifier to allow people to join the
chat group uh anonymously to share
because it's almost like a social safety
Checker you know so before you go out
and date somebody you can find out who
somebody is uh and who they're who they
know what they're about you know if they
have any past stuff it's safety pretty
much and the name of the app is uh
Little Birds you know like the saying
goes a little bird told me you know you
said you were single but a little bear
told me you wasn't you know
I'm in shock
it's so cool all right um I am scoobs I
am 27 years old uh a fun fact is I've
got free YouTube channels which is a lot
of hard work and
um I am in a relationship in a very
traditional relationship and honestly if
some feminists heard about the Dynamics
in my relationship they would lose their
mind in it so anyways
um my name is Lee Hilton I'm 22 I'm
currently seeing someone
um and I'm a musician
I am Joseph I'm 42. I'm an actor and uh
I'm an Arsenal supporter
you're a what supporter Arsenal what's
that it's a gunner
yeah I'm a football team
I don't know whatever it is yeah I was
like is it politics
uh yeah
um my name is I'm 29 and as you know I'm
a season seasoned veteran on this show
that's my fun fact I run out of fun
facts now
okay
so today's topic
is
what did I title it I forgot are modern
women prepared for winter yeah yeah
that's okay that's what I thought okay
so today's topic is are modern women
prepared for winter so
one year ago Kevin Samuels proclaimed
that a cold winter was coming for single
women
Mr Samuel spoke of a coming recession
that would lead to job losses in sectors
filled predominantly by women
the financial instability would lead to
more women getting evicted applying for
government assistance and seeking other
means of income AKA only fans and other
sex work no sector is safe from the
coming winter of over 73
000 Tech job workers being laid off in
the month of November 2022 in the U.S
according to news sources that time is
almost here inflation in the UK is
projected to rise to 18.6 percent in
January of 2023. the highest since 1997.
this inflation will apply to food and
consumer goods the most only 14 percent
of women say they are ready for a
recession in the next year the average
woman in the UK about 52 percent make 29
684 pounds a year
the average woman in the U.S makes about
36 thousand seven hundred and twenty six
dollars a year rent has increased by
12.3 percent Nationwide in the UK
rent has increased 17.3 percent to
around 2 550 pounds in London and as
high as 20 or 2 650 pounds in Manchester
women make less than men and spend more
the current way that women are
navigating their finances is
unsustainable with inflation coming and
the coming winter exacerbating the
problem putting feelings and emotions
aside women in general will need a man
because they are simply cannot afford to
live without one their survival depends
on it question for the women
actually and the men I'm gonna say and
the men have you first of all have you
noticed the cost of living increasing
and anybody yes yes yes yes
who hasn't noticed it
did someone say they haven't noticed it
no I thought I thought someone said no
okay okay I know so when I bought
kitchen roll it was like 450 and it went
up to like five pound fifteen and I was
like still the same kitchen roll so how
bad would the economy have to get before
you view a second income and a
relationship as a necessity
to the point where I can't afford no
kitchen room
dismissed from my family and like out on
the street somewhere for me to be asking
somebody like hey can I rely on your
income too I just and maybe I'm just too
independent for that but like it's it's
a joint income though it's not you don't
have to like get to the to the to the
very end of the road before you sit
there and say hey we have a better life
yeah if we pool our finances yeah it's
like if you make 40 and they make 40
That's 80. So then you have half the
round you just have to you just have to
like you know agree sometimes even if
you don't feel like agreeing you know
you know it's no I don't want to come
from I want to be homeless on the
streets
please sir have you got any change
um okay what about you oh god
um yeah I'm gonna probably align with uh
Kiara I
I would
rather just like get like a roommate
then compromise like under like I would
rather get a roommate or two roommates
before I went to being dependent or
having a part of my life being dependent
on someone else's income in like a
romantic setting okay that just would
make me really uncomfortable so you'd
rather have roommates than a man I'd
rather have roommates than depend on a
man in a real like I'd rather there's no
I would rather yeah have multiple
roommates yeah it would take a long time
to depend on the roommates though yeah
but that's a contractual agreement like
being in a relationship like the only
way that I would do that is if I was
like married or like we were working
towards marriage I wouldn't just have my
livelihood be intertwined with someone
who wasn't my husband or Gonna Be My
Husband okay what about you
so I definitely think it's easier when
you pair up with someone in terms of
like staying with them and stuff because
it is really expensive nowadays in
London especially I'm from London so I
don't necessarily think that for me at
my age I'd want to pair up with like a
man per se but family like roommates
friends Etc I'll definitely that be done
for it because the living costs are
really bad at the moment like it's and
the income's not Rising with it so it's
just it's not really making much sense
but yeah this is just not there
um but yeah I'd definitely be open for
it but I also think as well that just
for people that are like aware of the
condition just really trying to figure
out how you can bring in more income at
this point because I just don't think
like a job really can sustain people at
that or just one job yeah multiple
streams one income now is just not gonna
sustain people
I'm just not gonna lie okay what about
you um for me personally I have family I
have my dad I have uncles I have family
but what I will say is down to money
management and being aware of your
income what you can spend what you have
to expend with the cost of living like
for me I have a spreadsheet so I can see
how much things have gone up so that
means I can restrict I've always lived
by myself I've never had roommates I
don't have roommates now so you know not
everyone is fortunate enough to have
family
um
to rely on a man who is not your
long-term partner that's risky risky
yeah and if it goes sour you still end
up he could be your long-term partner
you can make it worse
what if it goes right
but I'm saying like if you're just
moving in from living by yourself or
living with friends to live with a guy
to rely on him for rent or whatever
that's kind of it isn't this how
relationships used to be families men
and women used to get together and rely
on each other to build a family build a
household potentially build a Str a
stable enough environment to have kids
in like I don't understand how we move
so far left from that that you'd you
would rather be homeless on the streets
you would rather rely on on on people to
live with you that you don't actually
know they could move out with their
boyfriend at any time no I do I do know
them for sure it's like if it's it's I
think it sounds more like everybody's
just scared to toe the line I mean I
don't I'm gonna push back on that
because like okay how things used to be
yeah people used to also be an extreme
really toxic situations like we're also
this generation we're all half of us are
child Children of Divorce or why the
relationships that should have been or
should be divorced so I think with
having that awareness of like what could
go wrong living what could go wrong yeah
we're gonna be so much more we're gonna
live in a fair though yeah I don't think
that's fear I think that's being smart
you know what do you know what the shift
came from the shift came from after like
the second world war right before the
second world war that everybody had like
this sense of Duty a sense of community
a sense of responsibility as soon as the
war was done everybody was like we're
liberate we're free we want go out and
chase your dreams be happy do whatever
you want to do two generations later you
got people chasing happiness that don't
even know what makes them happy and now
we have no sense community no sense of
togetherness and this is kind of why
we're in this situation now where we're
afraid to just realize that we all kind
of need each other I disagree with that
okay why do you disagree because we can
still have a sense of having a sense of
community isn't contingent upon having a
romantic partner well those two things
are not like that's where the community
starts because that's where your home
starts a romantic relationship is where
your home starts so okay so if you have
I have a question I have a question what
would you rather have at 60. a husband a
roommate or live with your parents well
obviously I would rather have them I'm
like I mean obviously I'd rather have a
partner like my husband however
that doesn't mean that I'm willing to
sacrifice I mean you must live in a nice
house boy because she's like I ain't
sacrifice I mean I do I do I do pretty
well for myself I'll be honest
maybe that is my privilege maybe I
should check my privilege that I haven't
yeah I I have I've been very fortunate I
have a really good job I I'm a content
creator I make extra money on the side
as well so like I can't fathom a
possibility
of my life going that way and so I think
it is because of that privilege that
that will shape my perspective
um so maybe I should take a step back I
have a question
um out of everyone here who has six
months of expenses covered if you were
to lose your job tomorrow so you do
six okay that's good not half
I don't know it's so one wait raise them
high raise them high so one two three
four five that's decent half that's like
more than I thought like we would have
what's down to the living though like
because I'm gonna have to go all the way
back by month six but I'll be here
whatever your standard of living is now
yeah yeah
beans are still good
um so have you guys had to make any
changes to your spending habits in the
past six months
oh definitely not not really yeah let's
take away
mine is cooking in the yard now I mean
it looks sad
and has and has your job industry or job
prospects changed drastically since 2022
or in 2022
anyone yeah well I'm a tattooist by
trade so my my clientele fluctuates
throughout the AOC summer time preparing
for summertime everybody wants to you
know get their tattoos done but then
times like now coming into winter you
know they have more
um different obligations and and
different avenues for their finances go
down so yeah this is this that winter
time is my time to chill out hence why
I've spent so much time with my other
projects
um so yeah I think everybody's feeling
like that at the moment
anyone else anyone well you mean what
like have you guys had layoffs at your
companies I've had layoffs at your
company what do you what do you work as
you said a content creator well well
that's like on the side this is on the
sidewalk and I'm I work in the tech
industry so I'm a Management Consultant
oh okay so text it's been hit hard and
tired yeah
and then I have friends who have friends
who are at Amazon or friends who are
Twitter none of my thank God so far
um none of my friends have been laid off
but
uh of a lot of people like that are all
most of my immediate circle are in the
tech industry as well so it's a tough
topic yeah it's not affected the
entertainment industry for me anyway
there's still films being made so it's
about wherever you get a job as an actor
or not so it's even more auditions now
yeah I feel like it's allowed people to
like think smarter into their like
investment choices so obviously before I
would work and spend money and just buy
useless stuff yeah like oh I want the
new iPhone that's coming out this year
so I'll get it and then obviously when
you get hit by something such as like
the cost of living crisis or a pandemic
it allows you to think okay how can I
think smarter make money that will
generate wealth and do certain things so
for me I've looked into stocks and
trading Isis and kind of trading and
doing stuff like that that will I can
put my wealth into something and then
flip it and generate more and then keep
on doing it so some things it's not
immediate yeah you know sometimes people
invest things into things that will get
them immediate gratification sometimes
it doesn't work like that but in 10
years I can say wow I've managed to put
a certain amount of money no matter how
much it is and flip it and in 10 years
time I can look into that and be like
wow at least I invested and now I can do
something else generate and like work in
something like property or whatever it
is I can invest that into something else
and flip that and I think that's really
important like with my generation
especially is
material objects they're not going to
last forever you can have the newest
Louis pouch but if you don't know how to
invest and kind of invest into your
future sometimes it won't last sometimes
you might be really lucky and managed to
do everything but I feel like sometimes
you have to look at things in a bigger
picture when you're younger and it will
help you manage to do it when you're
older and then you if you look at past
examples made by family members or
something like listen to your family
members because whatever they're telling
you you might think at the time oh
that talking like whatever but then when
you look at back in 10 years time you'll
be like wow my family really tried to
set me up for generational wealth and
tried to really help me get money
opportunities because they can see
things that you won't even see happening
yeah and I think that's really important
like yeah like my family were the ones
that taught me about generational wealth
and just being invest well and invest in
things that will make you profit and
help you in the future so maybe not
right now but in the future that will
definitely be an investment I'll look
back on and be like I did that or like
I feel like you're really fortunate to
like have family members who are able to
like guide you in that sense because I
feel like a lot of parents not
necessarily know how to guide their
children in like the modern world today
especially like with everything rising
and just this different environment
nowadays and I agree that
now for me personally I'm much more
cautious when it comes to what I'm
spending my money on now and obviously I
work a part-time job but I'm just
the same opinion there was like you
might want to get that thing or spend it
on that expensive shoe or whatever it is
that interests you material
materialistic things really are much
more like sensible now I'm thinking okay
I can spend my money on that but
maybe the budget and thing that you were
saying that dividing it into a sense
where it's like okay I'm going to put
that for that and put this down for
investing in my future investing in
myself in whatever form that is like you
said cryptos and stocks and stuff it
could be invested in your business
whatever it is like even if you want to
be like on social media content creation
whatever invest in them in that just in
yourself and whatever you want to do and
set yourself up for where you see
yourself in the future just so that when
you're at a particular obviously I'm
quite young but when you're at a
particular age you don't really want to
be struggling how people are struggling
do you know what I mean like or if
you've got parents as well that struggle
to like raise you and stuff like you
don't want to repeat that in your family
or in your in your generation or
whatever so you're trying to like work
10 times harder to make sure that you
don't repeat just family classes and to
a degree you know I mean I feel like
it's much more prominent now for people
to be cautious of not everyone but they
are like probably in my circle just a
large amount of people who are very
cautious of that and thinking ahead and
thinking in the future which I think is
very important extremely important to do
so if you're young it's like for me I
think it's the best years for you to
even think about your future a lot you
shouldn't really be wasting it on
like things that are just gonna go do
you know what I mean like sustain
sustain make sustained decisions
yes louder but also I feel like would
you sorry no go ahead oh would you argue
that like things such as covid and
everything play the factor in your
mindset now and how you think obviously
because kovid obviously loads of people
would have been made like redundant
would have been laid off and obviously
it made you think sometimes about your
mindset and it allows people to like be
like wow okay so I can't work at this
current time or furlough and everything
yeah so how well will I cover the
difference that I'm losing I think for
me it's more of a personal reason as to
why I'm like ambitious I'm motivated and
just dedicated to making those changes
for myself but I agree with the common
situation like I was one of those people
who was a victim of it like I lost my
job I had a certain amount of money that
I was just having to live off and it's
like it's just deduct and deducting and
there's no more gains because obviously
I lost my job and I was one of those
people so I guess it's like to a degree
that could have impacted my mindset and
I just started to believe that okay
anyhow you could just lose your job
nowadays and then what you're gonna do
if you know would you would you say
you're extremely Frugal now what do you
mean by Frugal like that's just not
spending a lot of money
um right now yeah I'd say so I'm very
cautious of what I spend nowadays to be
completely honest with you how do you
have your nails done then
um
that wasn't her money
it was literally my birthday
two weeks right it's not really get your
nails done if you want to get yourself
that is an investment in you girl I have
nothing against women
it just didn't sound like what you were
saying yeah yeah I hear your point but
it's like at the end of the day you can
put money down for certain things that
you like to enjoy I'm not gonna restrict
myself and be living a certain way just
you know I mean like you put your money
down for that you also put your money
down for that and that's fine obviously
it's my birthday I do like to look nice
spend money on my appearance I'm a woman
at the end of the day like this is a
very important thing so
um
what I'm just gonna say
um to add to what everybody said here
what I would say is one as I said before
do a spreadsheet set yourself goals that
you want to achieve don't watch anyone
just do what you're doing be resilient
yeah because life is hard it's not easy
sometimes you have to have setbacks you
have to lose money if you're gonna sit
and say I've never lost money I've lost
money I've been broke it's part of the
process I appreciate it it allows you to
have gratitude for your situation your
and appreciate the present yeah looking
at the future is always good and it's
the right thing to do but also look at
the present
I appreciate it absorb it and allow it
to just you know give you a bit of time
to reflect and then go forward from that
but set yourself goals so if you know
your money's getting stripped back you
can say okay if I say five pound here
five pound there in the future I
actually have more money to spend on
things that I like so you know so
question a question for the the girl so
you're you're 29 and I don't I'm sorry
how old did you guys say you are you're
okay
so I know you guys said right now you
wouldn't
um you'd rather live with roommates than
a man right that's not what I'm says
[Laughter]
the way that you phrased the question
you were asking us like how like where
would we have to be in our lives to be
an Alliant on a man in his income and I
think phrasing it that way like okay
okay fine fine but like when there's a
recession if you had to make a choice
right if if your income was getting slim
you would pick family over a man yeah
right
I have the option to do that so yeah if
I was in a relationship that's different
but I have the option okay so so let's
say like you lose your job tomorrow and
you have to think I either have to move
home or I have to get into a
relationship right right right now right
now right now right right now you would
pick moving home or moving in with a
roommate that's that's what you guys
said earlier I would suggest that to be
fair if you had no income coming in
moving in with a guy you don't really
know what his real Financial
circumstances and you might become a bit
of a burden and that might actually
crash the relationship yeah
I'm not I'm not I'm I'm just asking yeah
home for us I'm not responding to this
question
I'm just my question is would that
change if you were older if I was older
like if this happened at 32 33 34 35
would you ever start prioritizing
relationships over
um like moving home or moving in with
roommates me personally no I like I
don't view really or I don't even get
into relationships where
um money is a main proponent of that
like I I it's nice if we can go out on
like dates and we go out to eat and
we're going we're having a great time
and things like that but I'm also fine
with like picnics in the car and it's
just cheese and crackers like you know
like like it doesn't always have to be
well I'm not even talking about dates I
was talking about rent yeah
I understand like you're right like
you're in a situation your rent needs to
cut in half you either find a man or you
go home right exactly I'm just trying to
put it together like there's just no
situation where
it like even when I'm making money where
I'm going to be financially reliant on
the man I'm definitely not going to do
it when I'm when I'm not late I I
personally I would go with my family do
you want kids no oh you don't want kids
okay well then fair enough then you
don't need it yeah yeah I mean it I feel
like because even you asked earlier like
how how do I feel about being 60 years
old do I have a man or do I have a
roommate I mean being 60 and having a
roommate we're just out here you know
pushing little kids hitting people with
our canes like that sounds like a good
time like you can say that no sounds
like child abuse yes
I'm just curious have you always felt
like that
um you know different relationships have
shown me different things so I have been
in relationships with men where I was
like okay I could have children with you
I can see us moving in that direction
that can see us getting married I can
see us owning the house I can see his
reproducing and and like creating a
legacy that way
um but I it's not in every relationship
and even now that I'm single like I'm
definitely not pursuing that okay but
for it sounds like for the right guy you
still would yeah yeah yeah would you say
like your intentions changed before you
met someone so like did you think oh I'd
never want to have kids before I met
someone and then you got in a
relationship and you're like actually
maybe I would change my mindset or was
it always I'll never have kids in a
relationship with I don't have kids and
it got to like a certain point and
you're like actually but it so it was
more so like
I I don't know I don't know how to get
into this without saying like I I have
both of our families are pretty large
right all together there's 10
grandchildren right and so we grew up in
a yeah like yeah Summer's at Grandma's
house were always super fun and
um seeing sort of like the effect that
our parents had on us and like on our
other cousins and things like that it
was just kind of like I don't want to
have that effect on people
um and so when I got into a relationship
and I was like oh if we got together and
we were taking care of kids we wouldn't
have that effect on people we could
actually
builds like a very like beautiful
prosperous like family like I was like
okay okay I can see myself doing that
but otherwise it's just kind of like I I
can see us recreating like you were
saying before generational trauma like I
can see us recreating that generational
trauma and that's not something I want
to do that's a negative way to look
alive yeah
you're looking at the worst case
scenario but did you say yeah yeah did
you say your life is not full of
rainbows and sunshines like it's not
gonna be like all good all the time I
know bad all the time you're gonna have
to have a balance of both yeah so to
just look at the wrong that's happened
to you
but did you say you were from a family
that like I'm not sure if you said your
parents were still together my parents
were still together my parents are
divorced yeah okay and there's so my my
mom is her brother
sister
yeah so yeah but there's only two of
them so two people made ten
grandchildren yeah no that's a problem
surprise me yeah obviously because
obviously it was the whole what you said
I would would have expected it to be the
opposite obviously where you said that
you come from um your parents are still
together I would have expected the
opposite where you would have said um
you would you would want children
because obviously from what your parents
you've got two large families and when
it's come to like comes to festive
events you're all together that's what I
was surprised when you said that's why I
asked the question yeah like I'm the one
who wants yeah and it's funny to see
like obviously generation like true
everyone experiences exactly yeah I I I
I hear this question I've heard it on
your podcast before
um but nobody's ever like mentioned the
fact that the process of having kids is
like having kids raising children yeah
the best of your ability you know
without obviously going too far afield
and [ __ ] it all up I'm scared and
then you get old and your children look
after you like what happens when you get
old with no kids who's gonna look after
you and I think this brings up a good
point that we were making before you
mentioned community and you were talking
about how you would like your partner to
help you build your community with you
and I assume like your you and your
partner have kids and that creates your
community me personally like I I build
my community with like my church when
I'm going out to friends I go to like a
chess club like uh even like my work
friends and things like that like those
people are my my main community and I'm
not necessarily expecting them to
um like be by my bedside feeding me
porridge when I'm you know I can't they
might come through I'm sorry yeah
I have a question I have a question you
said so your church Community that's
where you'd find like that sense of
community when you're old interesting
um currently right now I'm still like
looking for churches that align with how
I personally experience Christianity but
yes like I'm looking for a church that
would allow me to do that that would
allow me to like rely on people work
with people if I needed food and I'm 60
and I or I mean
do you think that's realistic to expect
a church to take care of are you when
you're old this is what I'm saying I'm
looking for the right church and I'm
looking for the right Community like I'm
still I don't necessarily have my
decrepit 80 year old Community yet
[Laughter]
a sizable family like I will have
children my brother will yeah
are you honestly going to be like sorry
but are you honestly going to be as
happy as you think that let's say you're
60 or 75 do you honestly believe you're
going to be as happy like let's say for
example you have children and those
children that let's say you're 75 years
old you know let's say for example your
husband ain't there but you have your
children who are going to look after you
they're going to come and if you need
some shopping they're going to come and
shop for you and all of that [ __ ] do you
honestly think you don't want that at 75
because like let me let me keep it real
they might even at 75 man them out there
you know the manam you're looking at
right now they're not going to look at
you when you're 75. I'm sorry they're
gonna stop looking at you when you're
50. maybe even 40 right push it at 35
you feel me I'm sorry but like like do
you honestly believe that keep in mind
from like 30 is that someone's phone
sorry his phone was going off so I'm
going a bit of a run but like do you
honestly Whoever has found that is step
off camera and turn it off we started to
turn the phones off before the show but
go ahead I don't know who's found that
sound like a weird Mario game yeah yeah
mad takes but like honestly you're
sitting there
yeah okay I don't I don't know whose it
was
okay go ahead yeah sorry but do you
honestly believe like after the age of
35 like keep in mind women in general
they look for a certain type of man you
fool me like if a man who's five foot
two looks like a bowling ball you know
it's like it's smelly and all of that if
he walks up to you you're not gonna give
him the time of day you feel me so you
want a certain type of man okay right
and whatever your standards are
understand that certain type of man he's
gonna look for a certain type of woman
and I'm so sorry to tell you this and I
hope I don't get canceled for this but
usually women over 35 they ain't the
type of man they're looking for uh sorry
they're not the type of woman they're
looking for you feel me so do you
honestly believe when you get parts
sorry holiday I'm 26 26. you've lived 26
years of your life already you feel me
do you honestly and do you know how long
26 years are you know because you've
lived 26 years you feel me when you get
to that 50 you want to live up to like
75 80. do you honestly believe that time
by yourself is going to be an enjoyable
time
um so yeah so I'm going to bring up a
couple of points that you mentioned so
first things first like I don't want to
bring kids into this world with the
intention of having somebody to take
care of me okay so
the second point that I want to make is
that I happen to live in one of the
greatest Generations that ever exists
where if for whatever reason I
didn't have children and I wasn't able
to leave my bed I can just take out my
phone in Amazon whatever I need
it
stop stop everyone you can't go out that
same time don't you don't you think
that's Lonely no no you guys really lack
Community like and I'm not saying like
you specifically I'm saying like I I'm
able to find so much satisfaction and
joy and peace and goodness and and
fulfillment in in my friends and and my
other relations I think that's easy as a
young woman I think the point he's
making is the world treats you different
after like 45 or 50.
yeah so as a young woman like you're
treated better by the world and so
because you're young you're attractive
you're pretty and so and so it's like
you're gonna hit 45.50 the world's gonna
look at you different you start to be
treated like a man no I'm serious
there's I'm already bald I'm halfway
there the momentum stop buying new
drinks you going to see the world
differently you're going to the club
right now and man was like oh can I buy
you a drink oh you're so beautiful and
all that kind of stuff listen the moment
you hit 35 that's gonna stop
him
but like what is this man saying I love
the I'm speaking reality
I love the the concept of what's it
what's your issue with what he's saying
everything okay he's first of all he's
being so heteronormative like that like
these are a lot of assumptions that he's
making right now what is what is
heterono I don't know heteronormative is
just making making an assumption that
someone is heterosexual first of all so
as this entire line this whole monologue
he's doing is assuming that she's only
interested in men and that she's only
interested in what a man wants or what a
man could see in her I mean I think
that's not that's like that's that's
just not what life is like I I mean I'm
not gonna not just you're just making a
lot of some functions and running down
the street with them and I understand
the logic behind where he's coming from
like I'm not saying that he's being like
he's being illogical but because he's
basing all of his from my perspective a
lot of where your sounding board of
information is
is your foundation is heteronormativity
misogyny and the fact that like and it's
just not it's just not an alignment okay
wait it's just not in alignment with
where I where I find my foundation so
I'm like pushing back on the opinions
that he has so heteronormative I I still
think it would be sad if you were a
single lesbian woman so like I think
it's like a person like we're also like
making assumptions that she's single she
didn't say that she just said that she
doesn't want to have children in the
beginning well fair enough but like this
like whole conversation was under their
perspective of whether or not she would
be happy without having children and
then the second the second yeah I mean
it's a it's a valid question I think
yeah your answer could be I would be
perfectly happy but I just said you said
over and over and over again and he's
trying to like break down why she's
wrong and all these policies
points that maybe she didn't think about
and maybe she has and maybe like but I
think that's what we're supposed to do
on a podcast
and I'm exploring the idea that
so what do you what do you think what is
it that he said misogynistic I think
that like making this the assumption
that like her the prospects of her life
her future happiness is based upon
whether or not a man an objectively a
man would find her attractive after the
age of like what 35 that he said for me
is like
is like is a misogynist oh I think
that's true I don't this I well I think
that's your opinion yeah I mean I think
it's true I think most women aren't
happy that are that are single childless
over the age of like 45 they're the
least happy demographic that's
interesting that's interesting I just I
just could not get behind that I was
asking if you have statistics on that
really yeah there's like multiple stuff
what about single black women
black women like because like I feel
like the only reason I'm asking this is
because I feel like we like black women
from my perspective again I'm only
speaking from my perspective we are very
we have such a strong like sense of
community that like I I just we don't ha
I just feel like our our culture is
different so those types of Statistics I
think aren't going to be applicable
across what like what equipment I think
it's applicable
I think I think can I just say one thing
real quick right understand people like
I'm five foot six give or take half an
inch in it so that at the end of the day
my entire life I have felt the effects
of not being the societal standard of
what women expect to feel me so at the
end of the day like for example I'm a
man like I can't even cry about it and
be like oh no women don't like me
because I'm sure whatever all I can do
something about it for example for me
personally I started boxing you feel me
so like I started boxing and I tried to
show that you know what I'm on the
shorter side of things but I can still
protect you do you get it and like at
the end of the day life Frozen things at
you and you just kind of have to deal
with it now as a woman there are certain
things and I'm so sorry to tell you this
but there are certain things you can do
that can completely ruin it for you for
example
if you're a woman and you have only fans
I'm sorry but I'm not going to take you
seriously that's yours look
look understand I'm an average man I'm a
rich guy or anything like that but I can
tell you right now A Millionaire if he's
looking at you and he knows you've got
only fans he's not going to take you
seriously because there's certain things
us man them look for you feel me
I'm curious do any any guys any of you
taking only fans model seriously no no
I've not but you know what like
don't sit
they do for the money
girl you want to make
um sorry go ahead sorry
go ahead no so personally
I think
you can always argue like like people
would never take them seriously and your
value goes down but it depends what kind
of value you're looking at so like their
financial value goes up their sexual
value goes up no yeah
how does their sexual value go out so I
feel like once people see you've got
only fans there's always going to be
people in public they'll say no I'd
never be with someone from any fans but
check their DMS yeah most to be there
first yeah but check that DMS and you'll
see something okay I'll give you an
example look at Lana Rhodes she can't
even keep a man
that's one person from that I know
that's like what one of the most I would
argue one of the most I would argue one
of the most beautiful women I mean I
don't know I don't I'm not a consumer
but is that part because I feel like it
changes across the demographic obviously
see that's someone that we've looked at
from a different one but there's people
like you I'm not sure if any of you have
heard of Ruby Rose someone else yeah but
there's people and people look at her
and still be like that's still enough
yeah
so that's what I said her sexual value
went up but you'd still smash I didn't
say you'd want to be in a
relationships
your sexual value but your relationship
like what guy's gonna take you seriously
I know but then some people might I
think no no no I'm sorry I can't argue
for everyone I mean wait wait and I mean
I I mean
is Sim culture people are going to be
like oh do you know what your only fans
I see
can I just mention one thing
can I just say real quick like and this
is majority of women that need to
understand this right mandum we have two
separate categories right we have one
category which is for fun and then
there's the one category that is for
seriousness You Feel Me Now understand
when you see all these insta hoes sorry
can I say host that that insta host all
that that who are you know dressing up
in their bikini and all of that that's
us mandum like just enjoying a woman who
is being you know showing off a body and
all of that but that's a separate
category us man them when we want to
take someone seriously we're looking at
different things and that's not usually
the whole things that majority of women
are showing off these days do you
understand there's two different
categories that's the fun category and
the relationship okay were you gonna
suit her head upstairs oh yeah I was
just gonna ask like so would you guys
okay so we were talking about like the
millionaire wouldn't take the only fan
seriously and um most people say like in
order to become a millionaire you have
to have at least six streams of income
so would you guys genuinely in in a
relationship or even like as a married
couple would you guys pass off an
opportunity for a stream of income if
your wife was inviting you to create the
only fans content with you absolutely
this is one at a time one at a time okay
go go ahead uh to add to the um women
staying single and lonely after 35
there's a study that says that
women in this generation after they
reach 35 Plus they're going to I think
it's going to be like what half of the
women they're going to be single in
London oh it's when women actually it's
50 50 you got to stop you don't have a
mic like you've got one more chance we
have to go out so so it's 20 around 50
of women or 45 percent of women between
the ages of 25 and 45 are predicted to
be single and childless so much so that
big investors are so that means out of
out of all of us half of us will be
single and childless
um the one right there
um and and basically
um so much so that like places like
Morgan Stanley are investing in things
like wine cat food
and anything that like all the marketing
campaigns are like convincing women that
they could be young forever so any
marketing campaign that's basically
convincing women that like like what is
it ageism like you're beautiful even at
50. it's like come on
come on
real quick listen all right I really
don't understand I'm just going to sound
so misogynistic right now I'm so sorry
about this but like no no I really don't
understand women these days now it is so
clear
that there's someone I'm not saying it's
the government or Illuminati whatever in
it but there's something going on where
people are just trying to push women
into this industry where you're going to
have to work you're gonna have to be
this boss [ __ ] or whatever and like
understand this the only people would
have changed since 1950 are the women
you feel me that Madeline I'm Gonna Keep
a rule with you right now and ladies on
the panel take this in this game
really appreciate traditional things you
feel me that no I'm sorry to bring it to
myself but my girl is very traditional
and the reason I am so faithful to her
is because she is traditional you feel
lost
with submissiveness and all of that
sorry to try again oh my God okay okay
okay okay I'm Gonna Let You Go and then
I'm excited to hear what you have to say
and then we'll get to okay three points
to make okay one know your your category
and where you sit as a woman we all when
all of us are different we all require
different things we all like different
things so we lack a different type of
man
um two you said no we all like the seven
when I say when I say that I mean you
know physicality preference for example
I like black men that's my preference a
lot of women so you don't know I know
but that's a lot of what I'm saying is
we all know the reality is we
um we we all don't like exactly the same
things maybe in in if you want to be
generally we do anyway absolutely
second of all I just wanted to say on
the back of what you said
um and what Paul said can everybody
acknowledge there's less women than men
in the world anyway so this is I'm sorry
the other way around sorry sorry I meant
to say that we're wrong so there's more
women than men in the world anyway so
there's going to be more single women
it's going to be that way because there
is less men in um yeah less men in the
world
um if you want to have certain
requirements as a woman you either have
to be of a certain standard yourself and
I mean when I mean standard I mean the
way you carry yourself you know if your
body is what you lead with then that's
men just look at you as a physical
object and they will exploit that
because that's what men do and not all
men but if you're going to advertise
your body that's what men are going to
look at and if you want you know a lot
of women they will do only fans and that
kind of thing and then when they get to
an age where they're no longer relevant
younger girls are coming up better than
them no they're going to change then
they want to turn around and say thank
god oh please you know take me now and
the problem is the problem is with that
when you want them to take you you've
already surpassed your most I don't want
to say it's not about fertile it's not
but you've passed your Peak my name's
this natural that's the only thing
that's changed that for us is plastic
surgery makeup
um and so societal standards overall and
it's not everybody but realistically you
have to look at back in the day there
was no Photoshop everyone didn't
couldn't buy makeup everyone couldn't
change their hair every week you know
you had a role to play and if you're not
willing to play your role no matter how
big or small you think it is it adds up
it adds up that's it can I say something
no it's her turn so so my turn yeah you
said you had something you seemed like
you wanted to talk so I have so many
things okay go ahead but it seems like I
mean I'll I'll yield like someone else
yeah I think you I think you were next
and then you can go okay you had
something before you were raising your
hand oh yeah
um wait what was the original question
sorry okay now you can go you can go I
don't I don't really understand what's
the what's the push for women to shame
men for their standards like if men
don't women above 35 so what yeah I
don't know it's not it's nothing it's
like if I don't want a woman to be fed
am I fetching me like I don't understand
this it's like women can say they want
men who are six foot and they want a
washboard abs and all this and you don't
see men on the streets crying that they
that they're being you know where's the
the short short man positivity exactly
I'm sorry can I speak on that yeah
everything is massaging everything needs
to be true I don't think that that's
true no no I don't think that's true
take this in it's entitled to having
their own like no one's no one's going
on you for having me
wait I think that's I think that's easy
from like a woman's point of view
because a lot of times like we don't
notice it but it's like every time a man
has standards there's always a woman
shaming him for having them so like for
example when a guy says I don't like I
don't like fat chicks like then all of a
sudden he's fat phobic if he says if he
says I don't I don't like [ __ ] then
like they have then they have the [ __ ]
walk if he says that I don't like
um yeah but like every every time that a
man has standards he's shamed for it I
don't but I don't think that's a quote
unquote a standard I think that's like
that like the weight the way I'm
interpreting what you just said is and
maybe it may not be in the way that you
that you mean but when someone's saying
I don't like fat chicks like that to me
is fetching me no obviously
I don't like to date fine fine I don't
like to date fat chicks that's how
weight I I don't like to date fat chicks
but I can say on air I don't like to
date short man I'm six foot if a guy's
significantly shorter than me I'm just
not gonna go for it but as said we're
allowed to have preference women are but
men are men are but they think they're
different no no this is the problem and
I'll tell you what the problem is social
media has given people a voice a echo
chamber remember if there was no socials
you wouldn't really be hearing about it
you'd have to accept your fate as a man
and live and walk through it without
this Echo chamber like the podcast right
now because there's been a nature that's
I don't know being bestowed upon us with
technology we're constantly hearing men
have to have this men have to have that
and the reality is they'd actually they
don't they don't actually have to have
it yeah because the reason why they
don't have to have it is because if
they're the provider in the relationship
they have the power to to execute the
woman out of the relationship if they
want to if they're willing to lose half
of their property
do you think it's really that easy to be
a man and be able to provide yeah so
John I'm sorry yeah take this in right
yeah once again I'm a five foot six man
game will take half an inch right
majority of my life you have to bring up
women have told me to my face yo hey you
know what I find you attractive your
Vibe is cool but you know what just a
little bit too short you feel me that me
as a man I can't cry about it you feel
me yeah
you know what I've actually been
learning recently is that you can
um survive off of one income in places
like the UK and then the US I talked to
someone that raised 10 foster kids off
of ten thousand dollars per year and she
still maintains that income but the
problem is women spend frivolously and
they don't want that to go down in
lifestyle for a family typically
10K per year one person in the house no
10 people in the house
they're probably awesome okay like think
about it if you know yeah is that
written and stuff included
you move out side of the country and the
guy run like goes to the city yeah and I
just wanted to say to you because you
know I understand your pain what you're
talking about your experience right but
you're living proof you have a partner
that respects you you have a higher
quality partner than a lot of these six
foot plus guys yes or no yes or no but
here's the thing I
think extremely lucky and he's I know
Mike shout out to you baby here's the
thing you're saying this look it's not
luck because you're the man and you've
persevered
in your life I think that's I think
that's easy to say like what modern
women have ridiculous standards yeah
yeah women women always want an above
average man even if they're average
women yeah yeah they understand but this
young this guy here young man yeah this
gentleman here he's he's he's told us
he's below average height he's told us
that he was willing to go and learn
boxing he's told us he's got a woman
that is better than a lot of the women
that maybe come on this podcast maybe
better than me I don't know her but she
may be she's better than these average
women that we're talking about the
Modern Woman she's better than the
mother woman yes or no but I just
understand yeah yeah she is but
understand
at that there's a probability versus
possibility yeah and that one percent of
men who managed to somehow find one girl
no no no no but but as a man why are you
watching other what other men are doing
you I don't care
would you fulfilled your position he's
got a different goal yeah he's got a
different goal he's you've got a partner
no
um yeah are you happy with your partner
which is fine but if they get married
the women still leave 70 to 80 percent
of the time 90 of their college educated
so so wait wait wait don't cut me don't
cut me off if women still leave 70 to 80
of the time 90 of their college educated
so he could he could get that
traditional girl but that doesn't mean
she won't leave him later yeah but
that's a that's her probability that's a
risk that's it yeah that's a problem so
it's luck
but like I think that's just not like I
just try to empathize with men because
if I if I as a woman was going into
marriage knowing that I was going to be
left 70 to 80 percent of the time 90 if
I get a college educated guy [ __ ] I
probably would say [ __ ] marriage too
women I'm living in mass
please understand this why I'm in a very
unique situation my girl was Muslim yeah
you get it so she's got a different that
type of mindset when it comes to life
isn't it majority of mandum and the
reason I'm speaking on this podcast
right now is for the majority of mandum
I'm lucky I'm good but majority of man
them are no and how many girls did you
have to go through till you got oh don't
even get me Style
so how many how many bad bad girls did
you have to date before you found the
one oh my listen this is this is
okay okay just just give me a number
15. in the mid-20s range she gave me
yeah yeah someone found one girl who was
literally traditional and to the point
where I can be like you know what I can
take you serious you feel me yeah so how
do you sorry I'm 27 years old you're 27
you went through 15 girls to find the
girl that you require right so so you
are you are from what you've said you
are the Pinnacle you are the Pinnacle
your shoe yeah you did boxing you built
your masculinity in a way you got the
girl that you desire you got the girl
that you need for now no no but for now
for now
I don't think you understand like like
because men never know if a girl is just
gonna up and leave and I I just don't
like I don't think I think to dismiss it
I mean kind of like you're in a you're
in a happy relationship now it's like
even even if it goes to the distance and
he gets married like 70 to 80 chance
she's yeah Paul is that how you live
your life do you live your life like
that you've got a different reality the
reality is you're in a relationship you
like your relationship you love your
relationship you're willing to work on
your relationship you have a good woman
so you don't look at your relationship
and say oh it might fail so I'm gonna
just stop okay I do you go on because
like I said at the start of the
relationship sorry at the start of the
podcast I said yo man's got free YouTube
channels I'm working very hard yeah to
get myself into a position where I can
make enough money to have a good family
and all that kind of [ __ ] but sorry but
at the end of the day
like I'm taking a risk here you feel me
that's life life is a risk you walk
outside you might get hit by a boxes
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay okay okay okay but but it's easy to
say that it's it's very easy to say that
as a woman oh life's risk or whatever
yeah but you're not the one that could
potentially sign up to lose in the UK
it's up to 70 of your [ __ ] you could
work for 20 30 Years be 50 years old she
takes 70 of your [ __ ] I agree but you
then then you follow it and say well
life is about risk you can't just be
afraid I'm like well if you if I was at
a 50 chance that she can leave me and
take the kids yeah and and a lot of guys
have taken the risk and they've read the
brunt of that but at this point what
you're saying is okay get into new
relationships don't try that's not what
he's that's not what he's saying this is
what this is as a generalist statement
yeah we know there's risk I'm aware of
the risk I can see it's unfair for men
but as a man as a woman you must put in
effort if you're not putting in effort
if you see your partner no no no wait
wait I know you're getting angry but the
reality I'm not angry but you know I'm
I'm saying things that people might say
is contradictory I'm not a man I don't
have to live in your shoes I only
observe it and I've as I said many times
on this show I've had the benefits of
what men bring to my table and nobody
else can bring them to my table here's
the thing I want to ask a quick question
yeah it's not okay imagine you are a man
and really really and truly imagining
yourself because you're a woman right
and like you know all respect that
you're an attractive woman right so it
your entire life you've probably lived
your life man them come up to me it's
like hey what are you saying girl would
you get it like you've lived that life
now imagine you are a man right and
let's say you are at a disadvantage
let's say you are five foot two and
you're fat you feel me you're not gonna
get no attention from yours so you're
gonna have to put in and all that work
to become someone yeah that is even
worthy of attention not a relationship
not bedroom fun yeah attention yeah and
that should get it I mean there is there
is a girl there is a girl that pretended
to be a man like she was like a feminist
and she she dressed up like she
basically dressed up as a man for like
three years and she killed herself
because she couldn't believe how people
treat men well she actually got
euthanasia but yeah yeah but she went
and got euthanasia that's different she
didn't jump I mean come on man
how is it different did she know did she
not sign up to kill her show yes she had
somebody kill her
yeah okay okay okay
okay we're gonna okay okay okay we're
gonna we're gonna move on from this
um
okay so question for the men for the men
um have you ever dated someone with bad
spending habits and is that something
you look for and when you're considering
taking someone seriously so let's start
on this this side of the room and go
around uh yeah I think that a lot of
what I'm hearing right now is I'm
obviously 35 years old so I've kind of
been doing the 25 year old 26 27 all the
way to the point where I was like
something's gonna [ __ ] give with this
I used to go out I used to do the cars
the clothes the this the that
um and I mean those girls that are
chasing that sort of stuff I mean it was
it was fun for the while when we were
doing it you know I mean it was those
nights was crazy you were from you see
my knot there doing that big yeah all
right cool but then when the lights come
on and you sit down with your hangover
and your pockets are empty you start
going to yourself why the [ __ ] did I do
that for like you see what I'm saying so
enough of that and then also you start
checking yourself and obviously for guys
women can heavily influence that like
going out of your home is just splitting
bills everybody's buying balls
everybody's doing their thing but when
you have pretty girls especially pretty
girls or other guys in the club who are
flashing cash or trying to attract as
well you know it's it's [ __ ] tiring
man and I think that a lot of people
even a lot of guys who make a lot of
money will turn around and would say
that they would prefer to have somebody
that they could take that money with and
go on holiday or or buy things for their
house or there's so many other ways and
other places to spend that sort of cast
so I had to knock that one on the head
um me and my girlfriend like to cook
more now
a bowl of wine nice movie do you know
what I mean and it's cool I wake up
Saturday morning I'm like ah
I'm alive you know yeah okay what about
you the spending habit something you
look at
um when looking at a girl for a
relationship
so I was predominantly raised by my mom
so I feel like I always
I'm not sure I don't I'm not saying it's
a good thing but I always look at my
mom's example and what she did and what
she does in terms of her example and
sets for me and I always think okay if I
got into this situation or did go into a
relationship and your spending habits
were like this
would I
would I like the example you set say for
anything if we were to have children if
we were to do anything would I think Hmm
my mum would approve of you she'd say to
me oh yeah you're so lucky to have
someone that does this or would she look
at me a bit like
um what what red flags will you look for
red flags yeah
like what is there a certain lifestyle
of girls living that that you're just
like so yeah like for me it'll be if you
look at the next person too much if you
see someone's wearing this kind of
design on you want it and it's like you
follow by example you're not a leader
and that's just in terms of I want
someone that is a leader you know what
you want and it's not because someone
else is showing it it's because you're
like I'm a Visionary I'm gonna set the
example and I feel like I always look
for are you leading by example are you
being a sheep I'm following because your
friends see something and they're like
oh I want this this Balenciaga bag so I
want this and I'm gonna spend it on this
and then you're like you know what
rent's a bit tight this month I can't
pay it and you're like why so I feel
like I always look to the example of
would like in my head it's always with
my mama proof of you with Mom look at me
and be like I'm so proud of what you're
doing
and the person you've chose is your life
partner because if it's not then it's
like you can't stay and obviously I feel
like people always change so it's like
you never know at the start it could
start off really good and you could be
like wow like you're so amazing you're
literally everything I imagined but then
obviously everything's a facade
sometimes when you get into relationship
at the start it's always people are
going to present their best selves like
we can all argue you can get into
relationship and everyone's gonna show
they're a money man they're a money girl
they're about their business and then
you can get six months one year three
years into a relationship and then
they'll turn around and be like you'll
see the real them it's not even them
showing you it'll be it all begins to
fade naturally and then I feel like it's
always you kind of see everything for
yourself and I feel that it's always
important to if you see a red flag you
need to leave even if it's I'm not
saying straight away you're like oh red
flag let me jump out and run away now
it's like if it can it if it happens
continuously you either bring it up or
you leave and I feel that a lot of
people in our generation they might
decide to stay and they'll look at that
red flag ignore it and then you're
always just going to be in a cycle and I
feel like that's what past Generations
have done you've seen a cycle you've
been brought up in an atmosphere where
it's always been well if you see a red
flag it's fine because you always look
at oh they bring money to the table and
I feel like we always need to in this
generation ignore red flags like not
ignore their Flags we need to address
them I feel like it's always important
to address something that is bothering
us because in past Generations they'll
tell you yeah we've been married for 65
years and then you're like Okay so what
red flags were brought up and you chose
to ignore because I feel like that's
always an important question to him like
[Music]
that's always an important question to
address
I feel like oh it's more among the like
the younger kind of generation is like
we will the younger generation will
start jobs quit them and be like it's
not what I want and I feel like the
older generation are always the ones
telling you oh we need to stick it out
we need to you need to be you can work
in like Sainsbury's and they're like you
need to stack them shelves you need to
be like one of the best and you need to
stay at the job and do this and that and
in the younger generation you're like
nah I will skip this yeah yeah so um so
what about you spending habits have you
ever um passed over a girl for spending
because she has bad spending habits yeah
I mean I mean I've had experiences of
that I'm staying away from that never
going back to that just because I think
that someone that
has a bad spending habit and relies on
you to to to support that it's like a
sinking ship do you know what I mean
what was your experience with that well
oh she just wanted you to pay for
everything no I don't mind paper I've
never gone on a date where a lady I've
split the bill before in my life it's
just not the way what did that one girl
say um you can't afford me oh God
I run like I literally wrong safe let me
know like I really literally just run
away from those kind of women there is a
tick tock I saw it where it was like the
girl and the guy it was like two ups
workers and the girl was like you can't
afford me and he's like we have the same
job
it was funny but no no it's always the
way they try to make you feel less than
a man because of of whatever you can't
take them to buy them whatever fancy you
can go like you know take him to a
proper nightclub or something like that
and I walked in in like nightlife for
like 10 years and I saw this sort of
this sort of facade if a girl is really
about money then she can be easily
bought that's my opinion okay can be
easily bought by a next person so if he
even spending a couple dropping a couple
of bags on her it just all it takes is a
note is a bigger man to come and you
take her so she would never use it was
just your turn
what the men under swim like what would
you define as a a bad spending habit in
your opinion uh someone who doesn't have
you have priorities do you see what I'm
saying uh is my rent paid is my bills
paid is everything that I need to
carry on this month sort it out before I
go off and buy lavish uh nights out with
my girls or shoes or clothes or do you
know what I mean yes but having your
priorities in order first
yeah opposed to having it the other way
around so let's just say those
priorities are in order for a particular
woman but she still expects certain
things from you
are you now what are these certain
things you have to specify I don't know
like just to say she wants to go out to
a certain restaurant and she expects you
to pay for that okay well what has what
has she done in the relationship to say
that I so it requires her to be a
certain status in the relationship
absolutely so you're down for it it just
depends on well if if for example I only
see you on the weekends and you bring
nothing really to my life except for you
getting done up and wanting to go out to
fancy restaurants that's a no you know
if you're somebody who who if you know
what I'm doing and you know what I'm
about because you spend that sort of
time with me and I tell you about my
business and you go oh you know what I
might know somebody or how can I help or
whatever whatever you deserve those
nights not just how I got my [ __ ] done
girl I'm gonna take him you're gonna
make him take me out I said no
I hate what you're saying anyway
um my brothers
um they like won't date girls if they
feel like their lifestyle is too
expensive my brothers they all make six
figures and they can they can afford
like they could afford a lot for a woman
but like if a girl comes in expecting of
them to pay for all their [ __ ] and like
I don't know they just won't they it's
just too much of a headache I can't
afford you yeah
potential holes in this in your boat if
you're a man yeah and the Sheep
represents you because those are hoes
because what you think what you have to
look at is in long term about how that
woman is exactly you know how like if
she's like that and she's moved
especially through social media yeah
this is really like you know socially
conditioned to move by what was going on
in social media she's going to put holes
in your [ __ ] or imagine
I feel like it's harder to maintain
Financial kind of like expectation then
like emotional and like everything so if
you go into relationship
the kind of emotional expectation you
expect you you know it's coming you know
sometimes women will expect a certain
thing but if you're making the same
amount of money and we were like huh we
need to go on dates and you need to pay
for everything I want this bag I want
this like I want this hill I want this
and then you're going to look at it like
it's a bit much and it's like can I say
something
wait wait no go ahead what'd you say me
yeah yeah no I'm just like hearing these
scenarios and I would never go in to a
relationship with these types of
expectations so I maybe it's I mean so
I'm I mean I'm this is like a genuine
quick I'm I'm in receding mode like I'm
taking it all in like I actually never
really think to ask my guy friends these
things so this is interesting to hear a
guy's perspective but arm women saying
these things to y'all a certain type of
yes
but you know everything that we've said
has been generalized yeah and this is
and I think that this is the thing it's
it's a huge it's a huge um character
trait of women in America especially I
mean this is where it's all popularized
from the music the the hip-hop lifestyle
all the sort of all the sort of uh uh
icons but I'll give you an example so a
lot most of the times when I ask girls
how much they want a guy to make that
they would take seriously it it's
typically more than what they make
I would prefer to date someone that made
at least what I make preferably more but
like I would probably fit into that
category but I don't right to me that
way the problems types yeah but the
problem is like
um like what do you make over 75 000 yes
over a hundred not not anymore
roughly a hundred like maybe in the US I
made over a hundred and that was like
six months ago so 100 that's top 10
percent guy but
but I'm making no and that's and that's
fine but men don't care about your money
so that it's like nothing it's kind of
like if a guy tells us he has a shoe
collection it's kind of cool but we're
not like attracted to it we're like ass
it's okay I mean I don't know I mean I I
understand your perspective and I'm not
saying that you're wrong but like kind
of going back I'm sorry I don't remember
your name but Kyra Kyra what key was
saying earlier about this generation
like we were being cognizant of building
generational wealth like the
conversations I'm having with my friends
like my peers my friends who make over
six figures like my male and female
friends like we are thinking about like
all the things that he talked about
that's the com those are types of
conversations we're having we're talking
about who we're what we're investing in
what stocks like that's like what's
happening within my Social Circle the
problem is women women talk about it but
like the data doesn't Stack Up women's
how much more you think a woman spends
in a lifetime than a man Even though
yeah I'm sure we like I'm not arguing
with like whether or not we spend and
like that's not what I'm talking about
but what I am saying is that you said
that men don't care about what women how
much you make and I'm saying at least
within my Social Circles I haven't found
that to be the case because men that I
have communicated with men that I've
shot into you guys have dated especially
black men like we want to build
generational wealth like we've seen
we've experienced what happens when that
is not the Forefront of the of like the
relationship so we talk about goals like
financial goals that we have like
together like I so I at least that's
what I've converts like when I have
those those types of Standards or wants
I should say although I would like for a
guy to make at least what I make
um so I'm I'm curious um the guys that
you're talking to are they your friends
yeah yeah and and you make a good amount
of money
yeah I mean not again I took a pay cut
to come to the UK they're probably
trying to sleep with you
I have platonic mouths so I have a
question okay you call them right now
I'm saying I'm in I'm in I'm in what are
you from New York right from Virginia
you said Virginia you're from New York
okay you're sorry I'm in Virginia I'm
horny can I come over yeah
wait wait wait you're all my platonic
guy friends in a
relationships
wait wait wait wait wait so what why not
if they'd say no because what if I'm I'm
not interested
wait you can you can tell them later
you can tell no you could tell him it
was a joke it was on the podcast it's
video evidence I don't I don't feel
comfortable with that dude
so so I don't even want to know the
answer to that question the point the
point the point I'm making though is
like okay if a guy is a CEO of a company
that's like sexy to women it's
attractive to see a guy in leadership I
mean I'll give you an example and this
isn't to be political but like
Melinda or Melania Melania and Donald
Trump like she's obviously better
looking than him why is she like clearly
clearly why is she attracted him he's
the president that's an argument
okay but you see what I'm saying
right but but there's no men that are
lined up to date Oprah
Oprah no no even if she was single like
there's men Margot Robbie is married but
she's heavily desired like um Zendaya is
dating the Tom Holland dude but she
she's beautiful there's men that want to
date her yeah but it's nothing to do
with their money it's everything to do
with the way they look if she's if she's
hot and she has money they're like okay
cool but but it's not like they're
attracted to you for your money oh no
I'm not that wasn't what I was saying
either like I mean I'm obviously like
there's it's multi-dimensional like
there are a lot of things that go into
attraction like but again I'm used to
have this conversation of women expect
or want men to make a certain amount of
money and then you set the percentile of
like what those earners would be and I
maintained what I said earlier in that
there is a specific demographic of young
professionals who are taking what each
their partner brings the table into
account outside of sexual attraction so
but the the issue wait the issue is that
when you the the more a woman makes and
and I'm in this category too like the
more a woman makes the more likely we
are to be single no and that's true like
I I'm not arguing with that either I
know this I know that's like that's true
like I I didn't think about that like
myself like uh how far do I want to go
in my career because the further I go in
my firm the least the less yeah which is
sad like I mean that's like the less
likely a man will want to be with me me
yeah because like because I like that's
just like I'm literally like pricing
myself out as I continue to go yeah
because because our our pool gets
smaller and smaller and those men I
think about that yeah I do those and
those men want younger hotter tighter
no I mean like that's I mean yeah I mean
it's it's true it's not fun like I I I
wish like they cared but they don't no
yeah I mean that's just an unfortunate
scenario go ahead I'm sorry some
decision in my mind isn't stacking up
right you're having conversations with
uh your peers guys friends all in the
same sort of Social Circle same
Financial bracket yeah
um you guys are talking about how to
come together
um I'm I'm making an assumption
heterosexually yeah
um but at the same time in the very
beginning we said what would it take for
you to move in with a man and you and
you were pretty much like I'd rather run
away so on one hand you'd rather be over
here but on the other hand you're
talking in your Social Circles about how
to come together no that's not what I
said so when we talked about what what
are the two the two extreme options
would I rather move in would I be rather
be financially dependent on someone and
move in with the man or what I live with
the roommate and I chose living with the
roommate because I wouldn't want that
type of strain to be in my relationship
however I am a heterosexual I want I
might I want to get married I want to
have children like that doesn't those
two things would you depend on a man
like once you have kids 100 and I hope
he would depend on me that's what a
marriage is you're depending on each
other I know I mean like financially
yeah okay so you'd be okay with
depending on a man after you're married
after he's my husband after he's your
husband and I would hope that he would
also depend like that's you depend on
each other I agree I agree yeah yeah
okay yeah that was clear thank you
um
yeah I don't think you guys answered um
the you ever dumped a girl who comes to
financial like just bad spending habits
um so I'm gonna say this in a Christian
perspective because I'm I was raised as
a Christian so
um I never actually dated
uh
so this girl is the first time that I'm
going to a relationship and I'm still a
virgin and I'm a virgin because yes I'm
a virgin because I have to be a virgin
because in this day and age
I'm telling in this day and age I can't
be near any woman who like I'm not
saying this is this is like the general
of women who are like this but
um
they have their their expectations too
high and I I just don't want to mess
with with that and uh the other the
other thing I would say is
um
uh what I was about to say yeah yeah so
in terms of like spending habits
um I never had really to worry about
that but if if I let's in a hypothetical
um
uh scenario uh if she had this spending
habits of like going to designers shops
and buying jewelry here and then or like
you know like not not having a
um a goal in life in like
I wouldn't invest in this this and such
instead of she's going to invest in
something that it's like you said it's
not going to last that long so why would
I go through the hassle so I prefer to
be a version and wait to to be with a
woman that actually respects my decision
and respects
um
that
um
being financially responsible it's it's
a it's a duty for for both yeah that's
it
all right um just to clarify you were
asking about if people have like a bad
spending if you've ever dated a girl
with bad spending habits and that was a
red flag oh yeah 100 and um there was
this one girl I was with and sorry I
remember this one day where she really
wanted to buy it uh she wanted me to buy
her Timberlands and and I I was working
a normal job and I was making like 500 a
month or whatever and so I couldn't
really afford it you feel me but she
made such a big deal out of it and from
that moment on I realized there's a
major red flag you feel me I was like 16
or whatever and it's like the
entitlement yeah why are you expecting
that we both broke
you know how expensive Timberlands are
now it's like we have the same job yeah
here's the thing and ladies I don't
think many women these days understand
right
if you are a submissive sorry submissive
feminine woman who is friendly right and
pure
you have so much power and I think that
is the only time as a woman
you can kind of ask a man to be fully
like you know provide for you and all of
that because
the power of being feminine and being
submissive is a whole different level
you feel me like if I'm with a girl and
she wants to go out with her friends and
she's telling me Oh yeah I want to wear
this dress I know it shows my boobies
and all of that but I just feel
confident in it fam that's a red flag
for me you feel me like you are my girl
why are you showing your boobies well
that has that happened to you it's
happened to me in the past but I can
tell you about no Michael right now it's
not been a problem it's that it might
trigger some people but she asked me if
it's okay for her to wear ripped jeans
you feel me like and it's a whole
different type of relationship and I'm
telling you man them all you simps out
there because I've got to tell you
that's a simple epidemic right now and I
think it's because mandamore's all
desperate right now man them stop
selling yourselves in it like um don't
let yourself do the matters for these
hoes because at the end of the day there
are some good women out there who are
going to respect you actually let me
know you've allowed to you you gotta fix
on yourself in it go to the gym make
some money and all of that in it but
there are some women out there but these
Western countries America London and all
that social media messed up all of that
you feel me like there's a lot of
entitled women out there I'm not trying
to get canceled or anything but that's
I'm gonna leave it at that
can I just add to your point I just
think you know when going into a
relationship it's a partnership there
has to be give and take reciprocated
energy reciprocated ways of thinking if
your man has Vision I just want a
partnership okay okay you don't want to
partner equal Partnerships
I didn't say equal I said partnership
and you know sometimes it's in a
partnership is it's 50 partners are 50
50. no sometimes your relationship you
could be AE your partner could be 20 you
know sometimes it's 50 50 50 sometimes
it's 45 you know in reality social media
I agree has messed up a lot of things
for you guys there's a lot of pressure
on men to it to be financially basically
Invincible as I say Optimus Prime when
it comes to money yeah
yeah and you know ladies we do have to
look at the men that try for us the men
that really fight for us and push for us
you know at a simple day you know
there's a lot of symptoms in the comment
section what can I say they're
everywhere but it's an academic it's an
epidemic and we were epidemic there's
always a cure we have to look at the
cure for these problems we have to
represent
the the cure for the issue so we have to
have good relationships we have to
create those things to change the
environment that we live in
um and just to sorry to be all
philosophical about it but in reality
nothing's perfect so you know everybody
has their own experience and we should
you know enjoy our experience wait so
may I ask you would you think that's
what she's saying is very nice the
reality is very different yeah but you
know like I'm serious women live in
possibilities while women probabilities
so like women that we live in like this
la la land where it's like
that sounds nice but like women get more
and more delusional we get fatter we get
less pure we get less of less of all the
things that men value men value men
vality value Purity they value Youth and
it's it's us it's not bad because
because because
women are a lot we're older than ever
before we're less pure I mean like ever
I got praised for less than five bodies
how many [ __ ] got five bodies by the
time they're 31 which is the average age
of first marriage in the UK who's well
the reality is yeah let's we can be
pessimistic we can be negative you are
you are in control of your life right
negative looking at it's not negative
looking at facts this is just facts it's
brutal for men out here I'm trying but
it's always been brutal no no no no not
like this not like this I'm telling you
no no no no
take this
like these days in 2022 right you as a
man if you look at your girl and she's
kind of putting a little bit away she's
going a bit chubby and all that if you
even dare to try and say anything and
you yeah
society in which we live we have social
media and I agree with you that
validates things like oh you're fat
phobic because you said to your girl are
you putting a bit of weight you know
what if my man tells me I'm pulling a
bit away you know I'm gonna say thank
you for letting me know because it's
about something
[Music]
perspective why
back on all of this I if there are women
the most recent comment if anyone's
coming at you for having a job or saying
that you're broke because you work a
nine to five that person is quite
literally delusional the woman who like
that doesn't that doesn't make doesn't
doesn't even make a logical sense the
girl who's saying you need to spend how
much are Timberlands like 250 like on
half your income at what 16 years old to
buy me Timberlands like delusional like
I cannot imagine like even me I'm
thinking back to my 16 year old self I
would quite literally like my 60 year
old boyfriend if he like I couldn't have
met like I just don't understand where
these women are so you can't make those
generalizations okay I'll give you some
data and then I'll give you something
from this conversation okay what what
percent of the time do you think women
swipe right on dating apps 50 75 women
swipe right yeah right so yes like oh
like I five percent one one in 25 1 and
50.
not often five five to fifteen percent
of the time 15 is like the high end it's
it's typically closer to five yeah
because there's different apps what
percent of the time do you think men
swipe right on dating apps well they
swipe I mean this is what they've told
me they literally just swipe right on
everyone and then they just make their
decision afterwards right but okay okay
okay but think think about this why why
did they do that
so they can see their options okay right
because women's standards are
ridiculously high yeah that's why they
have to do that women swipe right or men
swipe right 45 of the time so so that's
on top of that okay second of all and
and I know you're saying like where are
these women but but you're that woman
because you wanna know and and wait wait
and respa you seem very nice but again
you're asking for a guy that makes more
than you which is 80 to wait wait oh my
God 80 to 100 000 a year that's a top
ten fifteen percent guy so so and then
the question is are you top ten fifteen
percent girl not money-wise but by the
things that men value and so even you
you might not ask them to spend that
money on you but you still want someone
that's in the top 10 15
and so women we have these crazy high
standards that men can't meet uh okay
can I respond yeah go ahead okay so I
understand what you're saying like we do
have extremely hyper like high
expectations values oh so sorry we do
okay sorry is this good hello okay so
yeah we do have these we do have high
expectations and I and I understand that
I am that woman as well like I want
someone who can make I I would just
prefer to make to have to be dating
someone that makes at least as much
money as I make because if I want to
have a child oh if I want to take some
time off work I don't want the child I
just I would feel more comfortable with
both parties we're bringing in around
the same amount of resources into the
into the family that's just what I would
prefer but we'll see what happens
I understand the argument that you're
making that okay we do have high
standards however this is like I kind of
going back to Kevin Samuels which I
literally like rest and made that man
rest in peace but like I got Kevin
cannot could not could never could do
that like maybe he rest in peace but
like not a fan not a fan me my
girlfriends like would drag this man he
did bring up some good points he did
bring up some good points like like a
lot of the things that kind of like
Samuel's like this whole narrative is
like women have unrealistic standards
then they're not willing to like make
themselves or like not make themselves
but better themselves to like so that
they're attracted to those types of guys
so a woman who doesn't go to the gym
that often a woman that doesn't have you
know specific attributes that the
typical man would like isn't even trying
to even more they get more of herself
but like highlight those things that she
has like talking about like being more
feminine and things like that I
understand that line of logic and that's
probably the only thing from Kevin
Samuels whole thing that I will get
online with because I do think that's
true you need to stay fit you need to
make sure that you're doing your job to
like make yourself better it sounds like
you agree with him that
that I'm coming from when I say that
women we have too high of Standards I
mean again I'm not arguing with you but
it's it's like average women too yeah I
mean I I mean that that is sad like when
you really think about it and like
you're talking about these statistics
like I think you take my taking myself
out of it like thinking about like the
50 auroras hundreds of there's a
hundreds of like thousands of auroras
out there that are kind of my
demographic right and I you know when
you think about the numbers that is kind
of you know it is scary and sad and I
just I think Kevin's point is like we
can want what we want that's fine it's
it's it's okay but like if if a a guy
that wasn't making any money wanted
Beyonce we would kind of laugh but like
when as women we can come forward and
say I want a top 10 guy and nobody's
gonna I just nobody's gonna look at you
twice and it's you know I think like
would I prefer a guy that makes more
than me yeah but do I think I'm gonna
get one probably not well I mean
but it's also not a and like I don't
remember who was saying and I apologize
but like there's so much more that goes
into like having a partner than like
like uniquely the money and I know what
Kevin said is like what Min values like
femininity if they're submissive like
sexualness beauty that type of stuff
women we value money being a provider
strength like these heteronormative like
like very clear gender lines can I ask
you another question how tall does he
have to be so you're I'm just
conversation all the time I'm five six
okay I was like you seem a little tall
yeah I'm five six I
so this is my thing my dad is six eight
okay so
I have my mom is five too yeah my mom is
five too I'm five six I have two my
sister my other sister's 60. I have like
tall jeans so I can afford like my kids
will be like again the whole natural
selection thing that's fine yeah give me
a height a minimum minimum the thing is
no no no please please
I really don't like I I I'll be honest
like like objectively I would prefer
like my ideal man is six two so ideally
but I've liked guys that were my height
before okay so so your minimum your
minimum is five six like or let's just
be honest five five seven five eight
yeah okay so five eight is acceptable
but you're not gonna be super excited
until unless he's six two like excited
about what like super attracted to him
super like you really want six two I
mean ideally yeah
yeah okay okay so that I want to feel
I'm not I'm not that's okay I'm tall too
I want a tall man too yeah yeah okay do
you want to be attracted to him I would
hope so okay so so let's take 10 of men
make more than you yes now half of them
are below five eight so that's that's
five percent of men okay now now you're
at five percent now you want to be
attracted to him let's say half of them
are ugly
that's two percent of guys
and and you have to compete and you
might have to share
because because think about it if you if
you find them attractive and he has all
the things you want that means other
women want him that means every girl in
this room probably wants him that
doesn't mean you have to share it means
you might
but this is options that still doesn't
mean that you have okay okay okay and
I'll give you an example so my dad is a
top one percent earner half a percent I
grew up in these families or in in that
family my dad didn't cheat but my mom
got him when he was broke so if you want
to get him on that level he's he's
probably gonna cheat you didn't help
build it like you didn't help him get
there like this like well it's not that
I want to think I don't okay why don't
you say something like because it's just
because okay but like people like
whether or not someone's gonna cheat on
their partner has nothing to do with the
amount of money that they get everything
but their character so so but okay if if
someone I just think men are men and
it's easy to say like let's take Tiger
Woods it's easy to say like why you know
why did Tiger Woods cheat but most men
don't have a Bus full of models waiting
for them and I think most men even even
good great men with character if they
are in a position where women are are
standing at the Finish Line begging to
have sex with them they might do it and
that's where a lot of the the top two
percent of men might be this is what I
always say if you dated NBA player
basketball player I don't I don't really
feel bad you get cheated on like I I
don't I mean again I'm cheating but like
I will always go back to this when it
comes to cheating regardless like
there's someone there's a five six man
that will cheat on someone who's
unattractive there's a six four like
beautiful man like true has nothing to
do with like how many women that are I'm
in my opinion everyone someone's
Unfaithful in their relationship has
everything to do with their character
and has everything to do with their
choices has nothing to do with like
there's some men that like okay I can't
but some men are more likely to do it
but this is this is my point so now you
want a top two percent guy that also
won't cheat on you this is a unicorn
and so even you you're a nice woman
right you you're Pleasant right and I
don't think you're asking these men to
be spend crazy amounts of money on you
but you're still a normal girl that's
that has that's asking for a top one
percent man and this is this is kind of
like encompassing the problem okay and
again I understand when you break it
down in that way yes like I can
understand like your line of logic but
again I'm gonna push back and say like
all the same thing is inverse like for
my partner wherever he is in this world
like all those things like I'm going to
fit all those all those like boxes like
that are against him as well like
there's someone like I and again like
maybe I am being delusional like and
that's fine because like I'm happy to be
delusional and most women are yeah I'm
happy to be delusional but like I have
there's no doubt in my mind that I'm
gonna be married and there's no doubt in
my mind that my partner won't you know
like I believe and I pray that like I'll
have it like so healthy so here here's
the problem like what do men want so so
if they looked at OkCupid like what when
do men swipe right the most I don't know
what that is 18 like Okay Cupid it's a
dating app yeah dating app men swipe
right the most on women that are 18. I
know that's I know that ain't fun
and and it slowly goes so men like youth
they like purity
and it's like give us control it gives
like they don't want someone they can
get no no
wait wait but see this is an example we
remember we said who are these women
that are shaming these men when men say
they don't want a girl that slept around
you say oh it's because they want to
control them but that's that's no that's
not what I'm saying but like they're 40
year olds who are swiping on 18 year
olds like they don't say I don't say how
long it's like they're like aggressive
like I mean like if you're saying okay
most men so like men that are on dating
apps let's say they're between like what
25 and 45 or like in their mid-30s like
swiping on 18 year olds that girl
doesn't have she has no life
I think I think
okay okay but but the point that's not
the point I'm making the point is that
men are attracted to Youth and Purity
and the problem is and and Beauty right
and like thin thinner women or curvy you
know you know slim that you know and so
like the point is there's a million
women that are pretty and Youthful
there's a new girl turning it doesn't
have to be 18 let's give 22 every day
okay I'm so more comfortable yeah we can
there's some studies that have said 21
22. I'm just giving you one that kind of
shows the extreme and so the the point
I'm making is there's a lot of women
that want the top one percent of men and
like that's why most women are going to
be single and childless is because we
all want the same guys
we want a guy that makes money we also
want to be attracted to him we also
don't want him to cheat on us and it's
like I mean I understand that but I
think another part of that is just like
women are like are which I mean the
other side to that coin is like why are
women's standards so high because we've
seen what happens again like being
Children of Divorce like we've seen how
bad it can be when you don't have high
standards like we've seen so like again
I I understand like when we talk about
like quality of life what about the men
I mean all these men I mean they're also
like that's the thing that's in the back
of my mind you're like oh all these
women are childless and well then also
there's a large percentage of men that
are awesome so like there's who are
these women potentially going to marry
like there's like not so I mean that's
also another side to that and I I don't
I can't like I don't have the statistics
you're the computer in front of you I
don't but I remember like having
conversation with someone about this
actually on a date um and he told me
that like men between the ages of like
single men between the ages of like 32
and like 45 who are saying angle are
more or like a specific demographic of
men that are most most likely
unfortunately to like analyze themselves
so whereas women are not like as likely
you're you're actually you're correct
like most of throughout most of History
men have not reproduced only 40 of men
have reproduced historically but that's
that's always been the way where 80 of
women have reproduced historically or 90
80 to 90 depends on who you look at so
it's odd now that 50 of women will not
reproduce and and now and you said what
will that mean for relationships moving
forward as women raise and raise their
standards it just means we're sharing
guys how do relationships no think about
it I mean you've probably been a side
chick at some point do how do how do you
really no no I know this is this is
crazy but I'm gonna explain it okay how
do relationships start sex or or a
relationship what usually comes first
sex What in in 2022 I mean relationship
for me okay so every person you've ever
slept with the relationship came first
Define relationship like like we got to
not not it so so usually in the
situation like this is you're my
boyfriend a boyfriend girlfriend I would
say it's like 50 50. okay so so in the
situationships typically that's a man
you find attractive right yeah yeah so
that means other women find them
attractive so you're probably not the
only one he's sleeping with so you kind
of start as a side chick and if you if
you do good you might get promoted to
girlfriends
yeah yeah in a way yeah because the
number one way people are meeting
nowaday are dating apps online and and
again women only swipe right five
percent of the time what does that mean
we're sharing if you're on a date if
you're on a date with a guy I mean but
we're all but like the inverse is also
true like we're also women are also
being courted by multiple men at the
same time so again like I I'm struggling
to that's that's true but of what
percentage so it's like 80 of women want
20 of men it's actually 100 but 80 of
women share 20 of men I don't like this
word share no I don't you don't like it
but it's true Did you you had a question
green so yeah I was going back to the
what you were saying before like what
standard is it you expect or you're
insinuating that woman should have then
like because I don't think you have to
settle yeah but I don't think it's wrong
to say I don't want a man that doesn't I
don't want a man who cheats I want a man
who earns a certain amount of money
that's
you know realistics or whatever standard
that woman is at and obviously just a
good real I just don't see what is wrong
with that expectation okay so I don't
think it's wrong to want a man that
doesn't you again again I again I was
raised by a dad that never cheated he
had 10 kids he was a multi-millionaire
he he had a lot of yeah he was nine
siblings yeah I have nine siblings yeah
yeah I mean yeah it's nice
what number are you um four I know four
but they adopt it it's a long story they
adopted some like later but it's okay
but but
I don't think it's wrong to want that
but the problem is if you're going to go
for a guy if you want him to be handsome
not just like uh okay handsome
attractive right but remember women so
women rate 80 and it's okay you guys
have never heard this stuff before I
don't expect you to know it but women
rate 80 of men is unattractive that's
okay but how many times have you heard a
girlfriend like oh but he's cute to me
like how many times have you heard women
like we we are historical women lower
our standards for men so much more
likely to do that right but but so no no
but remember remember women rate 80 of
men is unattractive so so top 20 of men
10 women might be like oh he's hot the
next 10 oh he's okay
which is which is fine you're less
likely to get cheated on if you dated a
less attractive guy that's not true okay
okay guys but this is the guys guys guys
again you don't think okay you don't
think a good good guy with character
would have a hard time saying no to a
model okay so listen right sometimes
when you date an unattractive guy the
second that somebody else starts giving
him attention he's like oh two people
are giving me attention at the same time
oh I I've never he's not unattractive
two girls two girls are giving him
attention no okay I've given attention
because his man's like his sexual what
is it his sexual rating goes higher
depending on the woman that he has on
his arm so like yeah so he could see he
could be this he could be a two but he's
with an eight he's immediately a six but
usually when girls say this they're not
ugly guy like if you could show me him
and I won't show it on screen but if you
show me the picture no usually because
I've done this on the show it's always
guys that I would rank a six or seven
and typically like girls will say oh I'm
dating medium ugly it's not medium ugly
that's just your level respectfully like
and I've been there I've been there but
like
but but it's it's just honest and so
it's like women want everything and even
like I also want everything no they
that's that's so again when the men
swipe right 50 what men swipe right like
the data just doesn't indicate that
because men find about half of women
attractive like it's actually crazy when
I started talking to men there'd be a
girl that I think is like kind of chunky
or like unattractive and I'm like would
you would you smash and they're like
hell yeah and finding whether or not
someone would like sleep with someone
does not mean that like he'll like go
take her out on dates does not mean
he'll take her home does not mean which
is which is fine which is fine but
remember it in 2022 it starts with
situationships typically so that's where
it starts I can't get behind this
because then earlier you were saying oh
men value Purity value
you're saying oh it starts with sex like
I I can't get behind this yeah yeah okay
okay yeah men do value Purity and they
like having sex
I'm just saying that like it's just not
adding up for me like the argument that
you're making oh I don't know it's not
an argument it just is what it is it's
like okay men will want to sleep with a
bunch of girls typically like if they
could do it the way they wanted to if
you know if they had a Bus full of
models waiting to sleep with them
they're probably going to do it but they
want to wife a girl and make the main
chair the girlfriend a girl that hasn't
been with a lot of people
it kind of can I just say something real
quick it's just like like I said before
I'm pretty sure I mentioned it like
mandam have two separate categories you
feel me one is for fun and the other is
for wifey and you gotta understand that
those women who are wearing these short
dresses they're showing off their body
and all of that they all go into the fun
category like us man the weekend you
know how okay let's put it this way that
women I'm sure you've all been in the
club before and a random guy approached
you and like you kind of can smell that
he's some kind of creep you feel me
right man them can do the same thing we
can smell when there's a hoe up like
talking to us can we not use this type
of terminology like can we not refer to
women as like hoes
I'm not asking can we use other words no
no but we're not we're not referring to
all women as I was referring to hoses
do we need to use that type of
binoculars
promiscuous women a man I would prefer a
man who took someone else's life is a
murderer right it doesn't matter what
you that you can try Dress It Up in any
way you can the fact is that Donny took
someone else's life now here's the thing
women that okay no let me put it a
different way humans right we all have
choices to make and one thing it's so
unfortunate but a lot of women to
struggle with the idea to understand
that your choices have consequences
first right men
take this in take this in right you
could be the most beautiful woman in the
world if you decide you know what I'm
gonna sell my body on only fans guess
what 95 of mandom are gonna look at you
and think you know what you're beautiful
you're cute but you're an only fans so
you're only gonna be in the fun category
do you understand like there's a whole
different category for women who act a
certain way who are going to be taking
his wife in material exactly and there's
a lot of women out there who that
they're living their best life they're
sorry that I was about to swear by the
effing a lot of mandum right and then
they're coming home at the end of the
things why is no one committing
themselves to me men are territorial we
don't want women we're territorial
I'm not trying to talk about my
relationship too much but let me ask you
a question let me ask you a question
you have a brother I'm sure okay do you
want only one though okay is he older or
younger I'm the oddest so yeah he's
younger okay how old how old is John he
is
would you want him to date a girl that
slept with two of his friends
he did oh my god did you encourage me
it happened after they broke up okay it
happened happened after they broke up
and he was he was it really hurt yeah
yeah no but I mean I mean but okay wait
so wait let me get this straight he
dated a girl and then she slept with two
of his friends afterwards okay so so
you've seen firsthand the damage it can
do to a guy
okay again I don't like this word but um
but it describe you know what I'm saying
no I mean anyone would feel regardless
like anyone would feel a certain type of
way like you think that your
relationship you think your relationship
is going one way and then you realize oh
like that clay wasn't as valued valuable
for her as it was for him so that's
disappointing for sure but and again
like I understand that line of logic I
would feel quite similarly if I was
dating someone but again this
I don't like this I don't from my
perspective I don't like or enjoy
conversation that is dictating how women
use their bodies but then doesn't do the
same thing for men
who are these like I I don't I that's
what I like if we're going to be having
conversations like okay would woman How
would how how would a man feel if a
woman slept with multiple men I would
like to have the same conversation about
how a man the inverse of that so okay
I'll give you I'll give you I'll give
you the examples okay so again we can't
undo biology so would you agree that
like when women start running out of
time to have kids like they start to
think more about it if they want kids
because we can't undo our biology right
so so the closer like 90 of our eggs are
gone by 30. exactly so the closer we get
to 30 we we start thinking about it more
right yes and it becomes more to the
Forefront of our mind okay so
historically men had to ensure paternity
there wasn't like there wasn't paternity
tests historically right and that's
that's new modern medicine so
if a man dated a girl that slept around
he wasn't he could potentially pass on
resources to a kid that was not his so
that's the biological reason why men
have evolved to not like girls that have
slept around however women it's the
opposite we have evolved to like men
that have slept around for example Drake
he's had a kid with a corn star
and he he clearly sleeps around yet
there are women lined up I mean so right
I okay there are other factors that go
into that there's other factors but but
you understand my point right where
Brittany Renner or whatever the you know
what I'm talking Runner Brittany Runner
there aren't men and Mia Khalifa there
are not men lined up to date them
okay okay we're making a lot of
assumptions okay we we look at Kevin
Gates
okay okay you could argue I think I
think you know deep down that men aren't
lined up to date them but if you want to
believe that but let me just tell you
the reason why so because if
historically we wanted a man that could
protect us and take care of us
financially yes so if he did that so
back back in the old days if I found a
guy that slept with you you and you then
I want him because oh he could protect
and take care of her her and her so I
want to get on that train so that's what
but we can't undo our biological Roots
so we still feel feel the way we feel
about it so you're saying that it this
is the second and summer summer is what
you're saying you're saying that when
from a perspective of a woman when I see
a guy who's been more promiscuous I will
see him biologically as a better
provider yes you you will be more
attracted to I'll give you an exam have
you ever been have you ever been cheated
on no no have you ever been cheated oh
wow I also haven't been in a lot of
relationships so okay okay typically
typically I girls most girls that have
been on my show have been cheated on at
some point
women like women that other women like
no no girl wants a guy that nobody wants
and I'll give you I'll give you a reason
why one it one in three men are either
virgins or haven't had sex in the past
year so if you wanted a guy that nobody
wanted there's a whole group one out of
three
but we don't want them
I disagree with that
how many ladies here
how many ladies here have a baby in
their friend zone do you get it
who has a guy in the friend zone like do
you know how many girls that listen I've
spoken to a lot of girls right and a lot
of girls have random in their friend
zone who would literally treat them the
best way any man would ever hold
on
they will give you everything you ever
wanted but guess what you ladies don't
want us toxic mandum
wait wait wait wait go ahead go ahead
um I just wanted to to add to something
that you said earlier
um so uh so in in America uh being
raised uh in a black Christian family a
lot of women are raised with impurity
culture which if you're not familiar
with that it's it's essentially
um basically like God finds more value
in you when you uh maintain your
virginity yeah I went to Catholic School
okay
um and so basically
um attached to that a lot of times is
also the idea that you lose value
um at the the more promiscuous you are
um which is you know but you see a
little bit of that in this conversation
that we're having but then you also have
the concept that like
um
uh all like men constantly want you uh
for sex and they constantly want you for
um as a sexual officer sexual object and
there are um specific even like passages
in the Bible that talk about like women
who were just taken like Angels by
different people right you know and they
just get taken because they were
beautiful and you know everybody had
their way with them and that that's the
story wait yeah wait wait wait my point
is my point is that like sometimes I
don't think people realize this that it
creates a mindset of hypersexuality
because sometimes as a woman now you
have to anticipate the hypersexuality
that you think a man is going to have
towards you and so you're just kind of
like oh we're having a nice conversation
they must want to have sex with me you
know and so so they do no no yeah yeah
so like like no man is is going to want
to date you if he doesn't want to have
sex no man's going to want to marry you
if he doesn't want to have sex most men
that are nice to you want to sleep
he's dating a woman right now yeah okay
okay okay now I have a question I have a
question I have a question what do you
want to do on your wedding night
I'm saying like I I guess my point was
that like a lot of men aren't uh bred
almost like from childhood to to
anticipate someone wanting to have sex
with them like as as a as the initial
point of contact in the relationship
whereas women are women are constantly
from like I can I can literally like
almost recite conversations that I had
when I was like in elementary school
where it was like by the way
growing up somebody's gonna somebody's
gonna want something for you and you
have to it's it creates a mindset of
anticipation which and creates a mindset
of hypersexuality which has this effect
that people are talking about but to me
to me I think that's honest that's true
men do want to have set like again when
you when you hit 55 or whatever day your
looks go you know um the world's going
to treat you different especially men
men absolutely and women talk about this
when they're in their late 50s 60s that
like men treat you that you get way less
attention from men but that I'm sorry
that wasn't my point my point is my
Point's not on like the attention that
you're getting from them my point is
that like
uh I we were talking about like whether
or not
um
the body count thing yeah yeah like the
body count thing like whether or not a
man who has no bodies is attractive like
biologically whether I would be more
attracted to him or not like I I like I
would I would love to have like pursued
a relationship where we were both like
waiting until marriage it's just like
it's just not
it's it's just not common there aren't a
lot of men there there are it's one out
of three like trust me if you want a
virgin go down to Tesco
[Music]
it's like it's like it's like okay
Walgreens let's go to Walgreens that's
hilarious go to Walgreens look at look
at the man behind the counter about five
six five seven that's so funny
okay okay go ahead it was just quick um
because I had this discussion with a
couple of my friends and even though
it's obviously
um the truth that men do want to sleep
with women uh most of them I guess women
wake up in the morning think I want to
sleep with a guy but women also
um
they set the level of what is acceptable
to have sex like for example at the
moment where scantily clad women are
popularized you know men don't feel the
need to put in the extra miles do the
extra work be wholesome as they used to
be you know when I have conversation
with my grandfather before he passed
away his
um memories of how he met my grandmother
it almost sounded like a movie to me you
know I wrote her letters she wrote me
letters back you know that was because
she set the premise of what she needed
before she had sex right and it would
still be the same today if women set
those premises for example if women came
together collectively and turn around
and said we only want to date men who
wear three-piece suits do you know how
many men would be down the road buying
three pieces running they'd be running
in shoes Dapper shoes and three-piece
suits but that's what I'm saying like
guys don't want to do the hard work when
the easy ones are there yeah they got
Tinder exactly yeah exactly but women
can come together and and change the
rules of the game then women want to
have sex like what you cannot have it
both ways you can't turn around and say
I can't believe men just want to have
sex with me because they just see me as
a sexual object but then at the same
time but women just want to have sex too
women I think that both people like both
like both like we equal equal it's equal
like both of them so I just think it's
it is like women want to have sex just
as much as men want to have something no
no wait wait I'm sorry okay
so the girls who believe that men are
just sleeping around we've had the
statistics 80 women are sleeping with 20
of men everybody likes to think that the
guys have all these bodies who are
giving these men the bodies women
presumably I would I presumably uh
making the assumption that it's a
heterosexual relationship exactly so it
is it literally is the women who are
giving these 20 of guys all these bodies
no I'm not going to push back on that
like if anything I feel like that's
something as an American I have noticed
that is different here like UK culture
like as like a young American Girl
dating here in London like the what the
women here and I I don't wanna maybe I
shouldn't say this but like it's just a
different standard to what to what I'm
using and again I'm from the south and
you think women are more [ __ ] here or
less [ __ ] I don't like these words
okay okay but you know what I'm saying I
think that women are more likely to they
just don't have standards here like I
just like in standards for like how they
want to be treated how it needs to go at
least from what I've it's like seen like
there's more homes in the U.S I have a
bomb shot I agree with that I have a
bombshell I'm actually it's prevalent
everywhere
people are having sex there's a hoedomic
I'm I'm from I was born in California
San Francisco raised uh until I was
about eight years old I moved here I've
been here from 11 till okay now uh I
frequent back in Chicago where I tattoo
uh time to time and being on both sides
of the pond through different times of
my life I would say that women over
America a lot more forward like the
amount of times I've had Whispers in my
ear in a bar or wherever maybe it's
because I'm from the south I don't know
like I mean this may be a unique
experience so I can't I can't speak for
American women it's just or American men
all I can say is from my experience like
men are more more traditional in America
like in America like women that have had
conversations with here specifically the
white women don't have any type of
expectation about how they want like
partner like relationships to go it's
very much just like we just have sex and
like I or like even dating like they
want they want everything to be like 50
50. like it's just or like from the big
like there's no according to like I just
from what I've experienced again in
London I don't know I think again again
and this is quite unique maybe I
shouldn't have used it if you go up
north is different yeah maybe you have
nothing I think I think it's a mating
strategy this is what I think so I feel
like okay all the girls want the top 10
20 of guys right so the girls that
aren't like attractive enough to get the
attention of those guys like through
recording they'll just sleep with them
because it's like 10 billion percent
yeah yeah yeah so absolutely but then
again if you had if you had if if the
standards were raised on both sides of
the of the field you know good men
wouldn't go for those girls
I mean I I
I mean from actually I can't speak for
men I can't but from what I've noticed I
wouldn't say that they do
you remember my app will change
no I'm telling you I think you you had
something you wanted to say oh no no
it's okay it's okay okay I'm gonna take
a second to read super chats um if
they're mean I'm sorry I just read them
oh
um okay guys like the video
um make sure there's over I think
there's over 3 000 people watching so
there should be over 2 000 likes in here
how many how many we got watching right
now a blessing well I pull up the suit
3.7
um also guys subscribe to the channel I
really want to hit a million subscribers
before New Year's
um so I that's a pretty lofty goal you
know we're only at 7 25
000 which is still crazy in eight months
but that delusion showing
um but make sure you guys subscribe to
the channel ring that notification Bell
um okay let me pull up the super chats
all these super chats are going towards
blessings monopod Okay C Dumbledore red
says I don't like these words chicks
love being the word police men use words
to describe reality women use words to
try to change reality
silly sausage they disagree and then go
on a 10-minute circle of absolute waffle
to eventually come back to the point
that they are wrong and then agree so
painful to communicate with you gals
sometimes this is honestly hilarious a
map butcher the couch of shame it seems
like you're struggling to make facts and
reality conform to what you wanted to be
you don't have to follow social and
cultural norms but try to understand I
hope Pearl didn't have any trouble
reading this you always roasted me about
how I read I know I know I'm not a good
reader okay amen thank you Dennis amend
Dania I'm lady in red I can appreciate
your young and naive about what men
think or want but she's a prime example
of where where women are lacking
education of the male perspective please
stop editing offers around you sheesh um
Clifford range Ladies by cat food box
wine and die alone she's trying to
police conversation it's in on feelings
guys the rest of them I'm just going to
read over twenty dollars um how is
Cheryl
oh wow
um Troy Francis is a marriage counselor
because both guys and gals have this
problem his classes fashion admin priest
mechanical he'll fix your courting and
marriage issues dramatic exits require
dramatic entrances are our dear host has
a skill set to find dating protocol
whether parties can see if their
marriage would work one great Gary
Champion's book is about soul mates
figuring out how to love each other
figuring out how long lasting fuel for
their marriage not the honeymoon phase
there are archers any goal or Theory
b-ball Scouts look for Shooters Rhythm
by when the shooter moves down with the
ball and then up there in their shot
motion dating takes logic and instincts
tier one SF candidates don't pass
election until they have logic and
instincts Davis parents are models of
success um sentience girl in the red is
shaming men's preferences but will
vehemently defends women's proud women's
preference 18 year olds are adults and
last I checked they don't come with the
emotional emotional and physical trauma
that the 30 plus women have it's not
about controls to ensure paternity and
avoid Shame about her past uh 2015 we're
gonna go down to the next 20 okay
um Manny fresh black men here who black
man here black man here who makes six
figures I don't care about my girl's
money and FYI generational wealth
creates family and kids
um
the okay I think that's Russell oh wait
that's the last Super Chat okay guys
like the video
um thank you for the super chats I have
one more question for the panel
all right why do you guys think women
are bad with money
I don't think women are bad with money
um
Yeah by and large our gender doesn't do
great I won't lie to you yeah they're
easily influenced by the by social
conditioning adverts social media and
everything that's going on I don't think
it's easily influenced I think it's what
you were saying earlier women are the
focal more ads now are being pointed
towards women and so but why we're
buying more things but why because I
think it knows more women are in the
workforce and more women have money
because they know because yo it's
because the brands know exactly why
because they know they can influence you
want your biggest Spenders are you you
know that great with you can be easily
swayed to have the what's the word
impulse buys all right I can I can give
you I I have it broken down don't worry
guys don't think all right a study by a
com guys whose phone whose phone is this
um okay a study by a company called
family financial showed that the average
woman spends
I think I said this earlier
526
374 dollars more than the average man in
her lifetime
breakdown is as follows okay I'm gonna
give you guys the the one two three four
five the six things and I'm just gonna
have you guys vote on on what you think
the women spend the most on okay there's
personal care products home ownership
feminine products clothing beauty
products and health care who here thinks
that personal care products
is the most when women spend no yeah I
think that's Beauty okay
so who here thinks it's personal care
products you two do okay two two okay
um home ownership who thinks that's what
women spend money on what I want it to
be
[Laughter]
okay all right feminine care products
you know we talk about the tampon tax
anyone feminine care no okay yeah we
know
um clothing
you guys think clothing you guys think
clothing okay okay beauty products and
everyone's okay they're changing beauty
products Healthcare yeah we talk about
women giving birth and [ __ ] who says
that is very expensive all right
actually I double vote okay well I'll
I'll just let you do that
the number one thing that women spend on
in a lifetime is beauty products
three hundred thousand dollars more than
men yeah
I'm not surprised number two personal
care products a hundred and thirty two
thousand dollars more
um number three Health Care sixty six
thousand nine hundred and fifty four
dollars
um home ownership it's like I can't
believe home ownership is one of the
last ones
um but it's on the list twenty girl not
by twenty four thousand dollars in a
lifetime
24th that's so bad okay okay extra money
you know what I was a feminine care
products a thousand nine hundred and
twenty I was proud of us for clothing
that was last a thousand five hundred
yeah have you seen this have you seen
what girls wearing nowadays it's like a
little bra little [ __ ] oh yeah there's
so much there to pay for well I just
think there's like sheet like there's
such fast fashion yeah it's like cheap
we're trying to get one away from Fast
fashion you guys okay go ahead yeah I
just wanted to uh go back to the
previous question of why women spend
more uh I also think it's because of
women have this Hive mindset they they
think like if if her friend is have like
uh the latest iPhone she also wants the
the iPhone if the other girl has I don't
know uh Balenciaga shoes she also wants
that while men are more uh analytical
and more critical when thinking why
should I spend on I don't know something
that's not gonna give me value in the
future that's gonna you know um
uh give a good Roi so I that that's what
I think and then spend so much money on
video games no no I think I think
subconsciously women women want to
believe that somebody's going to take
care of them yeah so they can be more
privileged
you know what's interesting this happens
a lot whenever we talk about something
about women like we always feel the need
to say but man okay but women do they do
the same thing you're like what no but
if it's if it's okay okay can we can we
disagree like if we spend half a million
dollar more dollars more in a lifetime
300 000 in a Lifetime on beauty products
that maybe we have a problem I mean but
we just had this whole what two hour
conversation about what men value
without having conversation like beauty
is the number one thing yeah that's true
I mean there's the there's a correlation
there's a correlation right it's
definitely correlation
could you argue that then women want
attention from men and that's the number
one thing they want if that's the number
one thing they spend on I think you can
make that argument I wouldn't say that's
I wouldn't say that's true and they want
to compete with other women
don't you could say women don't dress
for if you're gonna blame the men for
like like that being why we spend it on
it then you can't say women dress for
ourselves no I'm not saying we blame I'm
not there's no blaming here I just think
that this that we need to like think
about these things like from a bird's
eye view like there's like we were
having these conversations about like
how what influences behavior and I think
that when we talk about spending habits
that should be a part of the
conversation as well like I know a lot
of my like same thing like I do it for
the girlies like we always like get like
the outfits that we wear like I don't
think that men really care how our our
clothes match or not okay so so we spend
money on beauty products for ourselves I
think it's something I think it's I
think it's both I think like I want to
feel like 50 50. let's call it 50. okay
50 50. or maybe I'm wrong but but like
we can go like we like we like a well a
nicely dressed man like I think a guy
that's dressed well like a suit I think
a suit gives a guy like at least a point
like you ever go to like a school dance
and you're like I didn't even know he
was cute
and then I don't know when you're a kid
high school yeah you you what I was home
for like I went to high school when I
was home school
but um but they don't spend for like
frivolously like we do so like we have a
problem you know as women we spend more
we're not as good with money even though
we make less like we make ten thousand
dollars less than men or it pounds to I
don't know
and yet we spend more I think he's been
raising his hands yeah go ahead no oh so
hey thank you
um I have a theory and it went kind of
so before uh women I believe would wear
makeup to attract the male uh the
attention of men
um but I think as time's going on I
think girls more wear makeup to one-up
each other that's what that's what it
feels like it feels like girls are not
wearing makeup to one of each other
which makes the statement I don't dress
for men I dress for myself more relevant
but at the same time the the men come
with that do you see what I'm saying I'm
sorry
um so we kind of have that thing where
girls will get all dressed up wear very
revealing stuff tight form-fitting
things makeup done hair nails done but
then like we were saying as well going
for the top but only when the top
mail comes to you will you show a man
attention everybody else is kind of out
of it because you and your girls are
just trying to outdo each other right
and that's kind of what it feels like
nowadays you know normal men don't have
a shot with you because you know that
all the rest of the girls in your group
are like girl no he's you know he he
can't sit with us he can't afford me
yeah you know all of that stuff sort of
stuff
but I do agree with that many kind of
Fall by the wayside because girls want
to impress each other more than they
want to impress the man yeah I feel like
women do compete with each other and I
feel like probably because that's down
to the fact that the standard of men and
what they require is not as high as
women but they also have a standing of b
as well and if there's a friend that you
have or other women who you perceive to
be looking better than you dressing
better than you you're more likely to
think okay they're probably getting more
attention than I am or they're getting
maybe possibly those that person that's
the lights the likes that small
percentage of men that are hard to get
so in order to combat that
they are going to spend more money on
beauty they're going to spend more money
on their looks they're going to try to
be competitive yeah competitive yeah
absolutely I agree with that completely
I'm not I'm gonna I'm gonna do that all
day I mean but I mean
what's left for men when the competition
is over between you guys what's left
over for men after you went through all
the different men
in the UK so we're in the UK y'all get
around through 31 year old yay
I mean
it's crazy man it's crazy out here
social media has messed up everything
and yeah you're not gonna it's literally
just highlighted and putting them uh
magnified humans uh women's modern
women's true nature in terms of their
highly competitiveness they have amongst
themselves and also most times the idle
a pilgrimage Society we live in is also
if if a friend of a girl
goes out with someone that makes a
certain amount of money you must know a
bridge you're not literally shooting for
that she set the standard for the rest
of them yeah you understand what I'm
saying to you say you were cool with
like a hundred bags a year talking to
your mic say you were cool with 100 bags
a year yeah now like your projects not
gonna have a footballer that's making
that familiar yeah bro the 100 bags
they're all like the stadiums now bro
yeah yeah
the training grounds as long as you know
as long as you don't tell me I'm an
option I'm fine like yeah as long as you
don't tell me there's more I'm okay and
also I just want to say that
women who say there were makeup just for
themselves I'm sorry but you're 100 cap
you feel me like at the end of the day
as a man I can admit when I get a fresh
haircut
I'm doing this for women you feel me
when I go to the gym
listen my girl was irrelevant you feel
me like she's watching I'm sorry but at
the end of the day the things we do us
man them everything It All Leads back to
women you feel me and women do the same
thing at the end of the day you are all
on a podcast today and you made sure you
looked a certain way why because there's
certain amount of people watching you
right now you fool me like even even if
sorry there's biological like reasons
like behind makeup so like for example
blush um it makes your your cheeks red
and that's because that happens during
sex and so it's like a lot of the stuff
you might not know you might not you
might not know yeah you might not know
but it's actually like it's the same
thing with your lips red and it like
that have like your lips get redder
during sex and that's like an attraction
signal to man this is a fun yeah and
like like our eye makeup makes our eyes
bigger and it's because like youthful
yeah so it's I think I think I forget
the eyelashes like what that signals but
there there's a lot of like like the
behind the scenes of like why we have
the like the beauty products you might
not know but it's kind of interesting if
you look at the science piece it's
supposed to enhance the biological
attractiveness of a woman to use makeup
but we're at the point where we overdo
it like in some respects and what
happens is men I'm not going to say
they're not smart but a lot of guys they
look at women that are heavily made up
and believe that the women are not
making wearing makeup because they say
natural natural
um
listen I'm not generalizing I'll say
that there's some and they can't
differentiate between the natural face
and the made-up phase and then and then
they wake up in the morning when the
Miracles melted off I'm drinking is that
really yeah that's what I'm saying
that's what I said that's why they say
take your girl do a pool on a first day
because I haven't really said much after
our conversation here but my main my
point is before makeup was used to
enhance the beauty of a woman's face and
it was you know before this generation
before social media and all these
filters Etc it was about making yourself
look as natural as possible enhancing
what you already have yeah and now we
have a generation of people that are all
trying to look the same fulfill the step
the same phenotype the same prototype
and it's you know it's highly
competitive because now you have as a
man you have access to thousands of
women that you would have never had 20.
top 20 of men have actually yeah okay I
mean I mean okay no no that's what I'm
saying so for example if you're on an
app or a dating app you know you would
have even seen these women on the street
but you're seeing when mean maybe in
America
exactly of course and the same for women
a lot of these women they wouldn't have
had access to these men's and this this
unrealistic expectation it's been
Amplified and magnified by social media
is unrealistic let's be honest as a
woman it's a lot of pressure no is it
not a lot of pressure to look a certain
way to fulfill a certain you know it's
because of the women demand that
hey hey hey I was about to say for men
imagine they don't even have the makeup
they don't even have the finances to
wear the clothes and you know they might
put themselves in debt to just look good
for you you know what I mean so
but is it really that hard if there's
like 20 women who look like Kim K right
now
you can take it six and if she knows
what she's doing with her makeup she
could look like him yeah
do you think do you think that women can
get a boob job and say they did it for
themselves yes
so you're telling me that women right
let's spend X amounts of money yes right
let's keep in mind money ain't cheap
you're working very hard for that money
so you're telling me women are spending
all that money to look out for
themselves
what you're trying to look sexy for
other women you know baby you don't go
outside
stop stop one at a time okay you go
ahead no sorry I mean I'm just saying
I'm just saying I personally think
that's 100 possible like without a doubt
or even they're women who unfortunately
like sometimes like don't like are are
just don't have any like don't have like
proportionate for us to like to like
their body they want to feel like their
body like they might want to feel I
don't know
about the conversation right now is
about whether women enhance themselves
for themselves
I can guarantee you right now every
single man on this on this panel right
now can tell you that if when they've
been in a relationship you get that
maybe two three maybe four months of
your girl wearing makeup but after that
yo she's getting bare face and she's
looking at me sometimes she might even
look like a man you feel me
girls once they get comfortable they are
not wearing makeup you know what that's
like that's like if men got got dick
enhancements she said it was for
themselves
and they were just acting different you
know what it is like Queens the
princesses for anybody to enhance their
their sexual organs and say that it's
not for anybody else but themselves has
to be the biggest tease going like it's
like no genuinely I know you will find
me attractive but I'm not interested in
any single one of you so just look at
them don't find them just look at them
want to want to be you know want it but
even I don't think can I just say this
to close all of this back and forth down
all you have to do is look at this how
many people access plastic surgery
because they have a burn or a mutation
versus how many people access cosmetic
plastic surgery and that's it that
closes that whole argument look how
cheap it is you can go to Columbia yeah
and get like whatever you can get on
payment plans like in the UK we're more
likely to go to Turkey Etc but my point
is I'm not trying to dismiss anyone's
position but as a woman and I look at
other women and I see the plastic
surgery like on a day-to-day basis they
used to laugh at Michael Jackson some of
these women we see today they out they
out do Michaels
no no I I mean in the in the in relation
to if you look at when you sit on the
train in the underground the amount of
women that have got lip fillers
enhancements of course you can do what
you want
but the reality is how many women are
paying paying for this stuff on payment
plans that means you could never afford
it you couldn't afford it even if it was
in Dominican Republic turkey or whatever
so what that shows me is that you are
folding to societal social conditioning
yeah exactly and social media your your
your being acquiesced into that kind of
behavior don't forget that they're dying
as well I think it's vanity honestly I
think it's vanity and entitlement and
not just like like I'm sorry if you're
born a five or six you're average that's
okay that's normal but the thing is like
women are so entitled they feel like
they're entitled to the top 20 percent
of men top ten percent of men to be
honest I wouldn't say I'm a 10 but what
I was always taught is aim higher right
and a lot of women they aim high when it
comes to men they aim high and they want
okay I agree they want the same types of
men they want the same category of men
um but with makeup plastic surgery this
gives them the opportunity in general
women opportunity to feel like they're a
10 or whatever and the problem with that
is in five years time you're gonna have
to go back to doctor and get a a retouch
Joe the Kardashian messed everything up
that costs money and if you date a woman
who has plastic surgery and you're the
Sole Provider that costs you money
that's that's the problem I have so if a
man falls in love with you because of
your image and you have plastic surgery
and he don't really know because a lot
of women don't tell and remember there's
a there's a man that sued a woman
because he had babies with her and the
babies came out like her original
no
so this is
he actually won the case I think it was
in like it was like hey what should I
Google man divorces woman because of
plastic surgery it's in Asia I think so
the children they came out how how she
originally looked more
she looks like a different oh man I
gotta I got a blessing I gotta email
this to you hold on and just to close
because you know I think if you want to
do plastic surgery and some people do it
for you know if they have deformities
Etc but when you you know the bbls
putting your life at risk
what is that real sorry but you know I'm
sitting down yeah yeah so what is that
saying about your mindset you're willing
to risk your One Life to look a certain
way it's vanity
I think that actually shows it shows how
much better the world treats you when
you're a young attractive woman woman
and it shows it shows if anything it
shows that women are willing to die for
pretty privilege I guess I I don't okay
guys I'm gonna I'm gonna show I mean
it's sad but then like you know men just
have to deal with it like men don't get
that
um but wait she put it on screen because
this is crazy I can't even believe okay
okay
can you make it so they can see the
reactions
okay okay it's the it's the ugliest
divorce in legal history when husband
Gian saw his newborn baby for the first
time he was a horrified the girl was so
ugly he refused to believe that him and
His stunning wife could have produced
such a child
and he was rounded on his partner
accusing her of having an affair but she
told her him the terrible truth her good
looks were due to 62 000 pounds of
plastic surgery and the baby was indeed
the hit indeed theirs Furious Fang took
her to court claiming that she tricked
him into marriage and won the lawsuit
Fang said I married my wife out of love
but as soon as we had the first our
first daughter we began having marital
issues our daughter was incredibly ugly
to the point they're in
to the point to the point where and
horrified me his lawyers oh this is gold
thank you for telling me about this is
his lawyers told his he told his lawyers
his wife fooled him by having plastic
surgery to make her beautiful and it was
only the birth of their daughter that
gave it away incredibly the court agreed
and awarded Fang 75 000 pounds after his
wife admitted she had not told him about
the surgery a judge in nor a northern
Chinese Court said she had tricked Fang
into marrying her and granted a divorce
he also ruled that since Fang had not
been aware of the surgery his fight wife
had used false premises
and that is why and she and she gave him
back 75 you know all of his own money
you know what if she didn't enclose the
fact that she had surgery that's kind of
fraud still it's like the same way how
once again I'm a short man but if I get
surgery to be six foot and I told and I
don't tell the woman yeah I'm thinking
like I'm having NBA children exactly but
I'm like yeah I'm gonna have to false
advertising yeah that's fruit
can you imagine could you imagine
looking at your baby and going you are I
mean he's awesome
that's one more time one at a time I'm
just saying like that's a horrible story
and I'm like horrified for every party
the most horrified for the child
um but um he's also half the reason that
that child looks like that wow do you
just do you just speak up
yes I will
understand women
my brother with his two friends it's not
her fault I've never said it was nice I
never said that it's not just her it's
like it's like I don't know why like
women as women we have a gut reaction to
every time we
we say it uncomfortable or unflattering
truth about women it's like butt men yes
but we can but we can say things about
men and they don't do the same thing to
us well like if if I said on the Shelf I
said you know what
um there's a lack of masculinity in men
today a lot of guys would probably agree
they'd be like yeah yeah there is a lack
of masculinity
but that's what the issue but the but
the difference is like you don't hear
saying well but women lack this like
it's like but as women like that's what
we do like I mean I mean again I don't
want to push back too much but I would
argue I've had these conversations
because I consider myself to be on the
more traditional side like I like more
masculine men I want to have a
traditional you're traditional
traditional-ish like relationship but
the point of the matter is
I have a question are you virgin no no
you're a mother woman
I feel like you can still be traditional
yeah
so as a man no longer able to be
traditional if he's not a virgin
like you're putting men and women as
they're the same but throughout all
history no they're not the same okay
okay we can go back and forth men
protect and provide when women are pure
they're youthful and like they do things
like you got a cookbook
I also I have a cookbook you have a
cookbook like your own apartment house
your own recipes in a cookbook my own
recipe yeah no I have like family
recipes but I have like book like
cookbooks I've gotten as gifts but I
don't have my own recipes yeah some said
like traditional women got their own
cookbook their virgins they're 22. I we
had one I'm not any of those things I'm
26 but that's like we can have that cup
that's a side tangent the argument I was
we were talking about is whether or not
men are masculine and you're saying like
the whole butt women conversation so
circling back to that
I've had conversations with women I'm
admin here in the UK specifically and
talking about like oh like whether or
not men should be masculine whether or
not women should be masculine what if
masculinity and femininity exists
anymore if we're just like people and
like there is no there are no gender
Norms or gender and I've had a lot of
conversations with a lot of modern women
who who and modern men who are just like
oh yeah we don't want masculine men like
we don't want like and then or men don't
feel like these things yeah yeah so like
I mean so you're saying you can't make a
comment about women or sorry about about
women about saying the [ __ ] thing and
I'm saying well that does occur on the
other end as well
you're just competing with me guys guys
wait wait wait wait wait wait okay we're
not we're not ever talking me okay so
the the first part
um I mean women say they don't want
masculine man but then then they [ __ ]
the masculine ones like I see it happen
all the time they're like oh I I want a
more you know gender fluid neutral
whatever that's not something they have
sex with usually I mean I can't speak
for other people so I don't know what
people want I know I am attracted to and
that's all I'll speak for but but and
then the the second part
it's just not this like I just said it
in this room I'm full of men and I said
like men lack masculinity today and
nobody argued
and like that's that's my point it's
like we see that women also lack
femininity yeah yeah
the the point the point is the gut
reaction to anything that like puts
women in a bad light we have to say but
men instead of just like when earlier
when I said women spend more than men or
like women are bad at spending we say
well but men but it's like okay we spent
half a million more in a lifetime even
though we make last week we're bad with
money it's okay it doesn't mean we're
bad people ah
man okay I still I'm still gonna stick
up for a while
she could be like this asleep to that
but she's like yeah
I'm gonna like I'm gonna continue just
like I'm gonna continue like if I'm I
that's just my where my stance is
because you want to be right wait I
don't think it's happening right no I'm
not always right I'm wrong a lot of the
time maybe even more than half of the
time but I still will defend at women
even when even somewhere wrong yeah even
if someone
wait wait so did you just say you'll
defend women even if they're wrong oh no
I thought you said if I'm happy if I'm
gonna be wrong oh no no I'm saying like
well women are women are wrong you call
it out yeah so so I'm saying the same
way you would do with the women right so
I agree with you I agree with you but
I'm saying what the way you're acting
it's not the same so like okay I'll give
you an example okay women women's spend
half a million dollars more in a life
their lifetime than men even though we
make less money yeah but can I just how
wait yeah how how by and large are we
not bad with money how by and large I'm
not saying don't like don't please
please do not say there's exceptions no
no I was gonna say well if we throw the
Spanish into work and say okay women
spend more because they spend men's
money and they spend their money because
they work that's what it is so they have
more money because they're spending
men's money and they're spending their
money you could argue that because
there's more women on benefits and
mostly men pay into benefits so you
could argue that and they're also like
um the more there's more women that have
like student loan debt um like women are
I think 75 percent of like people in
college are women and with debt or women
and then we make 70 to 80 percent of
consumer buying decisions and like men
always have to bail out women for their
bad decisions so like for example in the
US right now like all the student loans
that are like they're trying to write
off it's mostly women that took out
those loans that they couldn't afford
and now the men have to pay it off so
yeah yeah you're right so they're
spending more money they have more money
to spend even if it's not theirs this is
my point they are spending more money
even if it's not there and then you have
that aspect but they're single and
childless so it's not like they're
taking money from an individual man it's
like Men at Large that aren't a part of
it have to pay for it as a society
society that is run by men supports that
and we as we acknowledge it's that run
by man women make 70 to 80 of consumer
buying decisions and we're getting close
to 50 50 in government because what I'm
saying is we acknowledge yeah that women
spend more yeah and that that has always
give or take been the case because men
used to work and give their money to
women right to spend it now women have
the choice to work so they have their
own disposable income which they're
spending on themselves and they're
spending the men's body single parents
were the different anomalies and not
anomalies but different groups but but
okay but the only Point are you
disagreeing back no no I'm agreeing that
women spend more money and that's
because society allows them to do so
yeah Society bails women out for bad
decisions like spending too much it
allows them to do it yes yes okay okay
um guys we're gonna do final thoughts
um so um go around any social media you
want to plug people can follow you I'm
not responsible if anyone sends you
weird messages
[Laughter]
um but anyways um any social media final
thoughts you're welcome to say it now
and go around in the second row
um I agree with what my cousin just said
that this was depressing uh just to hear
uh but I I appreciate the conversation
um I I don't have that big of a
Instagram following but you can follow
me at Queen kealabi uh Queen
Key island my first name
k-e-i-l-a-h-b-e-a
um and yeah it send me weird messages I
guess
I'm not responsible
you can follow me on Tick Tock at Aurora
period underscore Victoria and the same
for um Instagram
um yeah I'm not gonna say anything else
so my Instagram is anik.x
and just like my final thoughts on
everything I just feel like women in
general just I believe they do have high
expectations but I still don't believe
that women need to necessarily lower
their expectations I feel like you
should just set what you believe you
want for your life and what you want in
a man and if you're gonna get it you're
gonna get it and if you weren't you
weren't but it's like at the end of the
day
people can have their own expectations
and some of the expectations that I've
heard today I don't think they're unjust
in my opinion but
oh
um my Instagram is the CJ night
mommy
um [ __ ] sorry
um you can follow me on Instagram I uh
well my name is Inc underscore uh bye
underscore Steve
um my final thoughts on sorry it's on my
throat
it's probably all those butts hold on
here I'll let you do you want a second
yeah let me just okay so why don't you
guys go yeah
um
so final thoughts the last thing I want
to say whilst we're on this big platform
in that mandam stop being Simpson like
it's not going to get you any girls in
it so I just want to put that message
out there
um if you want to follow me on my social
media man's got free YouTube channels
one is a reaction Channel which is
called scoobs and reacts Scoops are
spelled with a z at the end and reactor
spelled with two Zeds all the other ones
that I've got a pets Channel I've got a
snake and a more real and I talk about
investing in Pokemon cards if you want
to check that check my insta Scooby
underscore Valentino links in the
description and that that's it really
and you can find me on Instagram Adidas
underscore base where I'm just playing
with my base and whatnot
um if you are into weird r b you'll go
to my Spotify uh Danny Becker Yeah final
thoughts
um
I just want to say this to virgin men
and virgin women as well as a whole like
don't be ashamed of being a virgin
because like I know Society gives you a
bad time but
um just stick to your lane stick to your
goals like just you know live your life
and don't worry about others think
because at the end of the day you're not
gonna be you know childless and single
and miserable you might have a husband
or a wife that actually supports you
because you haven't been through that
much trauma as I want to support it that
way so yeah that's my thoughts
final thoughts we leave in a very
we live in a very very uh in a terrible
world at the moment in my opinion
um that's what I feel uh women are
competing with men it's not good it's
destroying us we need each other we're
not separate and the continuation of
that is one situation where women are
trying to be men that's terrible I
watched the woman king and the Black
Panther and I was literally depressed
you know at how they portray black men
and feminizing black men at the present
moment and
I just feel like what I do know is just
terrible it's terrible I think things
need to things need to change
um
we need each other more than we need to
be separate and that's the world that's
the only way life is going to continue
we're making us decide that they're
going to be men and kids are becoming
women it's not the way it's supposed to
be that's my opinion but yeah my socials
my Instagram is I am Joseph sadeep
that's s-a-d-i-p-e
um on Tick Tock uh I am Li at Lil Joe
sudeep Little Joe sudeep and the same
handle for my twitch and I have a
YouTube I'm trying to get to hundreds of
subscribe subscribe Subs
so help a brother out in it
as you know my final thoughts would
always be the same to the ladies the
future is not feminist it's family to
demand them please just be resilient
stay strong there's good women out here
ready to love you ready to be your your
your partner your your your woman so
don't give up you know be a be a man and
like when I say be a man don't send for
me but be a man that stands his ground
and has Direction has purpose and um I
I'm sure the right woman will find you
and you will find her
if you're single
um I know something right no it seems
there's no simple damage the sympandemic
it will wipe itself out hopefully if we
stick to this and I just want to say you
know to everybody here and everyone who
watches the show you know don't don't
watch everyone around you you know look
at yourself be reflective be present in
the moment enjoy your life don't allow
social media to Cloud your brain cloud
the way you spend the cloud the way you
love just continue to be the best
version of yourself yourself and with
all the setbacks in life just look at it
and build yourself up because life is
not easy it never has been
um you know and what can I say but uh
just to close off I think that men and
women we need to work together more and
stick together more and if we do that
we'll end up in a better place if you
you know if you don't know my handle is
hey Hala
um I might accept it's on private but
yeah I'm there so there's like a private
Instagram oh man I have to I got deleted
the last but
um then you want to go anything else
what she said okay exactly what she said
yeah okay um guys a couple announcements
before we end the show um first if
you've watched two or more of my labs
and you do not subscribe we have beef
okay a subscribe is free and we want to
hit a million and before New Year's Eve
so make sure you subscribe to the
channel
um I'm gonna read the last two super
chats that were over twenty dollars a
men girl in the middle of your
perspective is not in sync with reality
hence you do not live in the real world
wake up ladies on the couch um from Zam
the ladies on the couch don't seem toxic
or anything but they're clearly out of
touch and tried really hard to argue
against basic points on facts with their
feelings on a tiny pool of personal
experience that's insignificant okay
those are the super chats um a couple
other announcements I'm the first guys
sign up for our memberships the first
lets you be a part of the live chat um
if you want to put comments during the
show um you have to be a part of our
memberships it's only five dollars a
month and it really helps us do things
like pay rent here so if you want to
support the channel we're constantly
getting demonetized on YouTube so make
sure you sign up for that because it
helps us
um the second is our Discord and our
Vlogs guys
I can freestyle rap and I know none of
y'all believe me but if you want to see
it sign up for the ten dollar tier where
I freestyle in one of our behind the
scenes Vlogs
um third tier you get to connect with me
on social media um that means having
access to my inbox fourth tier you get a
one-on-one call with me once a month so
if you need I have any questions about
starting a live show on YouTube I can
tell you the exact steps that I took to
get there
follow my Instagram just pearly things
one um my other one got banned so make
sure you follow that we're trying to get
to 10K can you believe it they took me
at 80. it's okay it's okay
um uh follow my Tick Tock
justperlythings.5 and six
um subscribe to wife school if you're a
304 and you want to be a wife DM me
um and also if you are a homemaker of
any sort and you want to teach classes
in wife school and you're in the UK
um we might be coming back to the US at
some point but right now we're in the UK
so
um DM me on Instagram just pearly things
one and then everyone always asks if you
want to get on the show DM the pregame
show on Instagram